ladies and gentlemen
a peasant revolt is upon us on reddit r
slash
wall street bets for the past i think
couple of weeks i mean honestly probably
for a longer time than we realize
they've been going after these hedge
funds these companies that are basically
betting on retail shops
going doing really poorly well they
decided to counter this move by rallying
everybody all these
small individuals with a couple hundred
bucks here and there to buy some stock
and things like gamestop
and amc to destroy effectively destroy
these hedge funds well all all today
we had people on the left and the right
cheering
watching these people buy stock in these
companies because it meant that these
hedge funds were going to lose
billions of dollars for once it seemed
that the working class people were
transferring wealth from the one percent
to them as opposed to the other way
around well
there's a lot to go here to break down
the story i'm sure many of you have been
following it it's huge
game stop stock went from like 18 bucks
to 350 bucks per share and this is a
company that
most people think isn't doing all that
well so it seems to be quite irrational
but
so the saying goes the market can remain
irrational longer than you can remain
solvent
i just read that today honestly so you
look i'm not a stock person
here's the bad news discord has taken
down
wall street that server for hate speech
yep it's only a matter of time when you
start taking the money from the
billionaires what do they do
they halted trading they they put a
circuit breaker freeze on some trading
they started calling for regulation one
on barons
uh a magazine they were saying we should
get a 30-day stop on gamestop why
because the billionaires were going to
lose all that money we can't have that
the peasants the plebs must know their
place now
the wall street that's subreddit where
all this is going on private
so we'll talk about all this we got a
bunch of other stories we got vladimir
putin basically saying we are we are
looking at a world war
ii type scenario we got this uh this
twitter troll
going to prison for posting a meme so
people say
but it did misinform people on how to
vote and
well it's a crime apparently this dude's
been arrested so we got a lot of talk
about we'll talk about this we'll talk
about wall street bats and ramifications
of this we'll talk about the stocks
but uh we have a really cool guest today
we've got jason whitlock how's it going
man
awesome awesome to be here thank you tim
for having me so who are you what do you
do
who am i i'm a long time
uh sports writer uh
made my name in kansas city missouri at
the kansas city star in the 1990s
and early 2000s writing
predominantly about the intersection of
sports
race and culture and eventually
got jobs at espn and fox sports
and went out on my own uh
recently i've i moved fully into tv
uh doing my own tv show at fox sports
one
and then went out on my own without kick
and now i'm a free agent again
uh about to do my next move and probably
try to you know move into the space
you're in
in terms of just being an independent uh
voice
of of truth and here more recently
i i still write about sports but i write
mostly about
race and culture and that's kind of what
i'm known for
as of recent i think you had a
particular critique of black lives
matter i think it's fair to say you're
you're not particularly woke
quite the opposite no no i am the whole
sports media landscape has gone woke
and i've and i've never been
that guy uh you know
i'm not political as i was i was telling
lydia she picked me up from the airport
i've never voted uh you know i never
wanted a political
identity now i am someone that was
raised in the church i am someone that
grew up playing football i went to
college on a football scholarship
and so those were my that's where my
values came from
football and the church and that has
painted me into the
you know i'm seen as conservative uh
but i'm still not all that political
although
here this last election cycle has pushed
me
probably in the next election i will be
voting i i'm pretty confident
i now i feel compelled that i have to
participate
in the election process because i'm
i'm so disappointed by what has
transpired over the last
few years oh yeah well we have a lot to
talk about especially with some
executive orders from joe biden and
critical race theory and all that stuff
so we'll we'll get into all that
we also got luke koski hanging out joe
biden would say some interesting things
about you if he found out you didn't
vote for him
also another thing before before
starting out here tim i got to correct
you here
when it comes to some of the censorship
happening right now we do have to
understand that the hedge funds managers
statistically are a minority
and it's important for the big tech
algorithms to you know
use you know to police all the hate
speech going against them right now so
so when you say hedge fund managers
are dumb it's hate speech yeah they're a
minority yeah they're minorities so
yeah a lot of hate speech going around a
lot of cracking of the whip so i just
realized
the 99 is the majority yeah yeah that
one percent is the minority
that's bigotry exactly welcome back
beautiful and amazing human beings my
name is lukadowski of we are
change.org if you want to find out more
about me you can check out my
independent media channel on
we are change on youtube thanks for
having me tim yeah ian's hanging out
what up everybody
ian crossland and speaking about biden's
executive orders i think he signed 30
in his first week they're about one of
them repealed or or cancelled five
uh executive orders so maybe that counts
as five even though this is
one it's a sign of the collapse bro it's
shocking the fact that we are getting to
this point where when like trump signed
an executive order on day one it was a
big deal
biden does i think what how many did
biden do like a lot more a couple days
ago was i think it was 30.
he did a lot more today right uh it's a
lot i don't
know the total i got to look it up when
your government starts relying on this
executive action just finger snap trying
to make things happen
it's it's decay it's it's it's the end
is nigh man i don't know what's going to
happen some people have messaged me some
foreigner friends i have a lot of
commentators in europe and stuff saying
it's not the end of the united states
it's the end of the united states as an
empire as this global force the country
is going to exist and be fine
but this is that change that's coming
and there's going to be inner turmoil in
conflict and it's you know
maybe going to be like the fall of the
soviet union he has the house and the
senate that are
democratically controlled and he's still
signing executive orders like a madman
there's a lot to get into oh we're and
especially with the wall street stuff so
we're going to talk about this this is
trying time
doesn't he have to get all this in
before kamala takes over
i guess that's what it is you know what
was looking at his watch what was
it like being like kind of a political
outsider watching the last election
disappointing i mean that's the only
word i could use for just because
my business has been built on
independent outspoken free speech
a search go wherever the truth leads
that's been my motto and it feels like
that's being
outlawed in america free speech
anybody on a search for truth you have
to
take some political agenda
hardcore and and it was
uncomfortable for me to realize
that as flawed as president trump was
he was our last best hope oh man
to retain free speech and
a lot of the traditions in america that
i actually love and enjoy about america
it's it it was uncomfortable to come to
that realization like
that's our last hope yeah i hear you man
well we'll definitely get into this
because i want to talk i want i want to
segue from like the wall street bets to
like
this collab stuff but don't forget as
we're finishing our intros we got star
patch let's press
i am here in the corner i am old enough
to remember when joe biden thought that
executive orders were a form of
dictatorship apparently he's changed his
mind about that since he's been in
office so this will be exciting
i'm thrilled right on and ladies and
gentlemen we have a wonderful sponsor
tonight helping make the show possible
i'm eternally grateful always when we
get sponsors especially in these hyper
partisan trying times
my friends check out
surfinginternetsafe.com
and you can get access to virtual
shields vpn service at 50 off
a vpn a virtual private network helps
keep your data safe here's the way i
explain to people
when you're surfing the internet you
basically have your doors and your
windows unlocked it might be convenient
you're getting some fresh air
you want to come and go as you please
you go shopping you come back with some
groceries doors open it's easy right
but it's not particularly safe and i
think most people would agree having a
basic layer of security to protect your
data from big corporations from
governments
a simple thing you can do right anybody
would tell you you want to lock your
door a little bit so if you go to
surfinginternetsafe.com
virtual shield is offering 50 off for
life right now and we got some we got
some points they want me to bring up and
i want you to know about
they say that the vpn service is
compatible with all devices
it allows you to browse the web safely
securely and anonymously using their
global network of servers and private
ips
it lets you browse the web completely
anonymously
so the big name internet service
providers and other third parties will
not be able to monitor
and sell your internet activity and
browsing history just the other days was
creepy
luke was talking about airsoft smoke
flares and then all of a sudden
our phones his phone's popping up with
all these advertisements we start
getting ads it's creepy stuff i don't
like it
anyway they say when using virtual
shield your traffic is routed through
secure and encrypted servers
this means that any restrictions
censorship or blocks on your internet
are bypassed
you can enjoy browsing on a fast
reliable secure and always available
network
and it's completely free for 30 days
it's good for it's good with mac windows
iphone ipad
android and chrome virtual shield does
all the work for you your entire
connection becomes secure private and
encrypted
and they route your internet through
advanced encrypted servers across the
globe
to prevent your internet service
provider from being able to track your
personal
internet history i think it's a good
idea um
it's appropriate when uh in in a
multitude of circumstances and like i
said earlier
look if you want to leave your door wide
open i think most people tell you it's
kind of crazy so it makes sense to have
some kind of service
check out surfing internetsafe.com you
get 50 50
off seriously thank you to virtual
shield and for everybody listening
virtual shield was my first sponsor they
they really helped us out for a long
period of time
i don't usually i don't shout them out
all the time but when that when you know
they've always been there
you guys got to understand man the
censorship stuff gets scary and we never
know when we're going to get put on the
chopping block so seriously ritual
shield we we love you guys thank you so
much
and for those that want to support us
directly go to timcast.com we have a
really great members only post up the
other day where tulsi gabbard called
cia's
john brennan and adam schiff domestic
enemies so if you want to hear us swear
a lot
at those people while agreeing with
tulsi because she's awesome become a
member at timcast.com
let's jump over to the first story and
talk about wall street bets
my friends cnbc reports the devastating
news
reddit group wall street bets behind
massive gamestop and amc
run-ups goes private invitation required
cnbc doesn't like wall street bets
because cnbc is where all these
crony hedge fund types and wall street
types go on the tv
and essentially it can manipulate
markets and trick
poor people into losing a lot of money
they say
wall street bets reddit chat room where
retail investors marshal against short
sellers went private wednesday
you must be invited to visit this
community the page now states
the forum's members topped 3 million as
of wednesday
the community gathered an army of rookie
day traders who go after heavily shorted
stocks pushing share prices higher
and squeezing out short selling hedge
funds my favorite part in all this
everybody loves it everybody except the
crony establishment elites but here's
what it looks like
you go to reddit right now you have to
be invited to this community
i suppose that means there's about three
million people who are still able to
easily access this and see what's going
on but if you're
you know layman looking in from the
outside and you didn't sign up like me
you can't see what's going on so let me
show you something real quick i just
want to show you the game stop stock
it's after hours is at 347
and 51 cents my friends some regular old
people
are becoming millionaires off of this i
saw a post from someone they put like
their life savings into it i guess and
then they made like a million dollars
i'm not saying that's a good idea i
think it's hugely risky
and to be fair there are some of these
you know wall street types
who are definitely saying a it's a big
mistake these people are gonna get hurt
some people probably will
that's why don't take any advice from
anyone anyone here on the show anybody
saying anything is not advice because we
got no idea we're talking about we are
not stock experts in any capacity
uh and i think for to a certain degree a
lot of people on wall street vets aren't
either however to be fair
a lot of people who go on tv and tell
you what to buy are probably lying too
yeah
now here's here's where it gets really
crazy this is the big the big big
drop discord bans wall street bets
for hate speech and that's it that's the
lie
that's the trick they've been talking
about how they have to censor everybody
for their hate speech
because they say naughty things that
offend people but what happens
when you get a group of people a large
group of people thousands tens of
thousands millions
who are saying we found out a way to
take the money from the one percent and
bring it back to the people
oh my we've discovered hate speech we
better shut down their ability to
coordinate
this to me looks like a dirty game first
they tried they
they halted trading on this on the stock
market it was a circuit breaker so
that's when like trading goes too crazy
they stop it
but then we saw that some of these
platforms like td ameritrade restricted
trading
so that we know what they're doing
behind the scenes the people at wall
street bets even think
that there's a coordinated effort to
manipulate the market to try and save
these hedge funds because someone's got
to bail them out
they could end up being in debt 10
billion dollars mean
they're gone now i don't know what you
guys think to me
this reaps a reeks of phony censorship
accuse them of hate speech that way they
can try and at least pretend like they
have some moral high ground
but who's buying it yeah i mean what did
you think when you allowed silicon
valley to aggressively police speech
what did you think was going to happen
of course they're going to be using it
and abusing it to help out their friends
their family members the people who
serve them
the people who give them money in and
this is huge according to s3 partners
short sellers lost 14.3
billion dollars just just on
game stock not even including all the
other ones
gamestop sorry games yeah game stock
exactly and then
other people other people are answering
back saying no no no short sellers
didn't lose
people won and enriched themselves to
the tune of 14.3 billion dollars because
all the
market i mean you know manipulators all
these hedge funds managers that
are absolutely hated by the left and the
right are finally getting a taste of
their own medicine and a lot of people
are realizing hey
it's only capitalism when it benefits
them and we saw
massive massive pushback by cnbc
freaking out
cnn wrote an article how trumpism
explains the gamestop stock surge are
you
kidding me i mean if if cnn couldn't
absolutely hate it when wall street
hedge funds managers don't get their way
from
don't get their pound of flesh from main
street this absolutely exemplifies it
it's absolutely sickening when the
little guy wins
cnn is always going to be backing the
big guy it's crazy trump
trump is um yes trump's done i saw a
post with someone they're like wow trump
disappeared real quick didn't he he's
out of the presidency and like
we don't see him we don't hear from him
so what does cnn do
well it's trumpism i i knew it we said
it was coming
they're really out of touch because it's
just like a bunch of kids well i know
they're all kids but like using reddit
forums that's not
has nothing to do with trump's been
around since before trump they did use
that tactic to get trump elected
he here's what is new though guys
and since covet
there's a lot of working-class people
stuck at home
their jobs have been shut down uh
if you're in the service industry res
you're not making near the money that
you used to make
many of the people have lost their jobs
and so
listen i don't want to cry broke here
because i'm i'm not broke
but i will say this about covid and what
has happened
is that i got heavily involved
with my td ameritrade account i have one
that my financial advisor runs
and then i have my own little one that
because of covert and i was at home more
i started paying a lot of attention to
and if there have been stories written
i think like 16 million people have
signed up for their own
personal accounts and so what i think is
going on here
they're calling a time out like wow we
got
16 million new traders there's some
people that read it that have figured
out
they've gathered up people that have
been put out of work the working class
and they figured out how to make money
and we have to call a timeout
and figure out how do we respond
to all of these new traders and and this
new economy that's going on in the stock
market
and so they're coming up with excuses
while they try to figure out how they
stop this disruption
that it's taking their money away bro
yes
but just think about what hedge funds
represent the destruction of the little
man and the small
businessman the individual restaurant
owners the individual
stores and provi everything is walmart
everything is amazon everything's this
big
global chain and i think these people
and again i don't have a full
understanding of wall street bets and
what's been going on
but it just feels like the working class
fighting back
and the elites call in a timeout we've
got to figure out well that's what
that's what the nasdaq ceo was
considering today
thinking about holding and stopping
trades to recalibrate their positions to
of course combat people on reddit
and now people on reddit are even you
know pushing their discussions making
their groups private which is absolutely
crazy here
but one thing that you also brought up
during the whole coronavirus
uh 2020 year stock market speculators
were the only ones who made
record high profits while everyone else
was wiped out
people will realize this people
understand that this is not right
because when we look at hedge funds
managers the people on wall street
they don't provide any services they
don't provide any goods they literally
move around zeros on the computer and
make more money for themselves and
people are scratching their heads like
hey if they could do it
we could do it as well it's fine if
someone is like yo
i got 10 000 shares at a dollar oh it's
two dollars i'll sell it i just made a
bunch of money
it's another thing when they start
putting shorts on stock where they're
basically betting someone's going to
fail
while saying we're infusing money but
what i'll tell you what the problem is
okay fine you want to short sell
something going to take that bet it's
risky i accept that too you want to make
a risky bet you know what i don't like
is when they short a stock then they get
their buddies to go on tv and go
oh it's going to be bad you better sell
now and then everyone panics and the
stock crumples they start laughing
because they manipulate the game to make
money this is what they are reaping
this is what they get and and the best
part you were mentioning this with covet
and all that
a lot of these people young people a lot
of these people needed money real bad
and it took months for the for for the
congress to get these checks out to even
negotiate these things
and some people were desperate got those
and used what they couldn't do what they
did
but there are some people who had some
lying around we just got 600
stimulus checks got sent around now you
get a bunch of bored people
sitting around with their robin hood
accounts td ameritrade
and then someone says hey you know those
fat cats who made billions of dollars
off our back while our economy collapsed
you want to stick it to the man and
they're like what have i got to do you
got a couple hundred bucks i sure do
from my stimulus drop it in my favorite
thing about this is the establishment is
being hoisted by their own petard you
know my favorite they want they want to
pump out these billions of dollars
1400 stimulus checks are coming and what
do you think is going to happen what a
much of these young people are like
screw it and they dump it all to target
these short it to short squeeze out
these hedge fund managers
robin hood dude yes that's what robin
hood did
stole from the rich and gave to the poor
and now we're seeing it again
digitally that's not a not a coincidence
if this really is a simulation
dude yeah and of course yeah you're
talking about an app that people are
using people are using cash app
people are using robinhood i personally
tweeted out my like uh
my cash app and people are like oh
you're you're set you're you're selling
uh what was it shovels during the gold
rush here and i see what you're doing
here
and i'm like yeah i mean it makes sense
now of course i'm i'm always very
skeptical of reddit because i know
reddit could be manipulated
i know the stock market is fully
manipulated so we should be cautious
here
uh and another thing to kind of really
really consider here is
wait until wall street bets wait until
that community finds out about bitcoin
okay i mean there's also another huge
potential here of people saying well
we're going to invest where
things actually matter where they
actually make an impact and this is a
sign that a lot of people on the left
and right are seeing as this huge merger
point of people
finally coming together putting their
political differences aside and saying
you know what
everything's rigged let's play the
market just like they play it i
you know i hear what you're saying but
you know what i think is more likely to
happen is that the hedge funds are going
to panic and find bitcoin
because they're these shorts are being
attacked all right
so i'll try to explain it i may be
getting it wrong because i'm not a stock
person so you guys can super chat and
then we'll get to that but the general
idea my understanding of a short
is that i'll put it this way like ian
let me borrow that share real quick i'll
pay you for it next week
i then sell it to luke for 10 bucks i'm
hoping that in a week it's worth a
dollar
so then i'm holding 10 bucks here's your
dollar for the stock you lent me
right i'll pay you back for it now but
what happens when i sell it for 10 bucks
to luke
and then a week later to 100 bucks and
then you know ian comes to me and says
all right 100 bucks is due
but i only have ten dollars i don't got
the stock anymore so what they're doing
is by
by everyone buying into these stocks the
value skyrockets
and then the crazy thing is these hedge
funds who short the stock
there's no bottom it's a near infinite
potential loss
if the gamestop stock goes to five
thousand dollars which i'm not saying it
will
then for every share that they sold at
six bucks
they owe that five grand and they only
got six bucks
so they're looking at what do you say
look like 14 billion dollars lost
just on uh according to s3 uh partners
just in uh game stock uh alone
i am not offering advice advocating for
and encouraging anything but i will tell
you my opinion oh man i love it
i love it so much i got mixed feelings
because it
it's dangerous for people to coordinate
and and game the stock market like
but it totally goes on every day that's
what they do that's exactly what they do
that's the name of the job listen listen
look at who was it loffler and perdue
were they the ones oh they were the ones
who
they they moved these stocks around uh
leffler
they moved these stocks around just
before covet or whatever and they got
called out for it and they said it was
totally legit
and we weren't the ones who did it sure
wealthy individuals with connections
with access always know the right moves
to make
it's just convenient isn't it but also
let's just think about
the really wealthy people and the
connected people the globalists and
you know i'll get fried for using that
word maybe i don't know but
the global when they're shutting down
the economy
sending everyone home put mask on you
can't work
they see the stock market crash and the
globalists have all the money to
invest in the stock market as it crashes
and they've benefited and everybody
knows that if you've got a brand you've
been following
the rich made a ton of money
during colvin i'm embarrassed and i'm
not
i'm not super rich but i'm embarrassed
by how much money i've made during covet
by buying devalued stock and then
sitting back for the last six months and
watching it grow
it's embarrassing how much money i've
made sitting on my rear
end at home it is a transfer of wealth
from the working class to the rich
and when i hear about millions of
regular people saying i got a stimulus
check let's let's let's do it
you know what that is we had a bunch of
people storm the capital that was dumb
they accomplished nothing they're going
to charge people sedition nothing's
accomplished from it
the state now the feds are like we want
more security powers nothing gets
accomplished
i'll tell you what really scares them
when you go after their pocketbook when
the regular working people
figured out a way to stick it to the man
and so they they panicked so hard it's
hate speech
they're bigots economics is our only
solution
yeah again no seriously we can't count
on the ballot
anymore we can't vote them out but if we
can make them pay an economic price
for the exploitation of the working
class then you have a shot
yeah i'm loving the left and the right
together on this one
i'm seeing like like leftists you got
kyle kalinski you got vosh they're all
like this is fantastic you got
right-wing individuals cheering for it
and i'm sitting back like yes
i mean this is this is why we've been
saying voting with your dollar is
extremely
important and when we look back at
previous movements like occupy wall
street
you know we could make fun of them we
could ridicule them but one of the major
success stories was them
disinvesting from major big banks and
investing
in smaller community-based banks and
that's one of the success stories that i
think
shook a lot of people from the core and
i think a lot of people are shook
especially from the reaction from the
mainstream media especially from the
reaction of big tech
and also from the from the response that
we got from the white house today
as biden's press secretary was asked
about this
and her only response was do you know we
have a female treasury secretary
literally that was her response and that
the female treasury secretary by the way
janet yellen former head of the federal
reserve who also gave
speeches to wall street to the tune of
millions of dollars she enriched herself
for giving speeches to wall street and
also was a part of the same institution
that bailed out all these big wall
street banks and firms
during the covet scandal we have to
understand there was a huge transfer of
wealth that no one wants to talk about
where the federal reserve
printed a crap ton of money and
literally
gave it to all these speculators gave it
to wall street so their losses were
literally
privatized their their you know profits
whenever they make money
that of course is pure capitalism but
when they lose money the government
steps in
now they have a potential of losing more
money because of independent small
action of redditors
and now they're freaking out talking
about look but we have a female
look how diverse we are are you kidding
me you know what's funny about this
is that what we're watching right now
are these billionaires
having their wealth redistributed among
this community of three million people
and i'm like that sounds awfully like
what these socialists have been calling
for for some time
but everyone's cool with it because it
wasn't done through government
it was done through the market yeah and
so everyone like so the left is
basically like well it wasn't government
but you did redistribute wealth
and then people on the right are like
these monopolistic oligarchs are getting
what's coming to them and it's through
the market everybody's happy we gotta be
careful in the coming years because i
think this is gonna continue
this like coordinated stock buys and
sells and stuff be careful about buying
stock on margin this is what happened
during the great depression
you can't give advice okay but during
the great depression what happened was
people the
economy was booming and everyone was
like oh you can buy stocks to make money
well that's awesome i'll take out a loan
to buy stocks
and assume that the stock's going to go
up and it kept happening and people kept
taking out more loans and more loans
and then one day a month excel happened
and they called a margin call which is
uh the stock's down so you're gonna have
to pay
for the loss with your loan and people
are like i it's i i don't have that
money i took a loan out
to buy the stock in the first place now
it's worth less i owe money and then it
would dip
more and the people that sold
immediately got out
but a lot of regular working-class
people lost their wealth so
listen must stress you got to get your
own financial advisors because we are
just a bunch of morons who know very
little
use history as a lesson as a book as a
history book
not financial advice but me personally i
don't i don't invest any money that i'm
not afraid of losing
whether it's you know cryptocurrency
silver gold bullets
even stocks personally i'm not going to
spend it if i can't afford to lose it
that's me personally not telling you
what to do not financial advice we have
to stress this
enough uh because again i think all of
us are involved in the stock market in
one way
you know or another and we have to
disclose this and there's
a bunch of weird particular rules
surrounding this particular issue like
jason i got in during covet to the stock
market
i love the saying that the market will
remain irrational longer than you can
remain solvent
so these people who are placing these
bats or or buying on margin
when those calls come in and you gotta
pay up you might be like that's that
makes no sense
why is gamestop at 350 bucks it's it's a
it's a failing retail market doesn't
matter
the market speaks and so what we're
seeing from this in my opinion
we got joe biden cranking out executive
orders like nobody's business
like history right i just kind of 37
presidential elections
but they're presidential actions i don't
know if they're all executive orders
well because they could be memorandums
but either way it is it is trying to
establish in effect changing the rules
changing the law
this in my opinion is a sign of decay of
the system
the the legislation's not working
anymore joe biden's comment and he's
just rubber stamping whatever they want
then you also have people showing how
broken the market is for a year when our
economy was in shambles
people were making billions off
speculating you got people their stock
value skyrocketing
and i understand it's not liquid cash
right they're getting net worth and that
value
but traders were selling and were making
money they were getting liquid cash out
of the system
while everyone wasn't people weren't
working then we saw the government print
all this money trillions of dollars and
they're going to do it again
the system is in decay this to me is a
sign of major instability
i'm not entirely confident about what
comes next you know we've we've talked
about civil conflict
you know whatever you want to call it
what happened man i got to tell you
when we've talked about like weimar
germany and the mass printing of money
and people shoveling money into the
gutter and stuff
we are looking at this crazy economic
instability
what happens when the system shuts down
when they try everything in their power
to stop the people from rising up so
what do they do we're halting trading
we're circuit breaking the stock you
can't trade anymore
that didn't work well then ban them for
hate speech
people are going to be like that's bs
dude you keep changing the rules and
moving the goal posts
every time we figure out a way to stick
it to the man to find a way to finally
get the wealth out of the hands of the
one percent they change the rules again
and when the rule changes don't work
they scream hate speech
eventually people are going to say the
system is so broken
there's no point playing anymore and
then it falls down yeah and but
again a bigger point to add here no
matter who made money today we also have
to realize a big fact here that tens of
millions of people woke up
to how the game is rigged we had a very
we had a vlog
them up yeah no what woke them up cnn
cnn nbc
i mean we can make another argument that
but again today is a very special day
because it is the rare occurrence where
wealth
finally transferred from wall street to
middle street usually it goes from
middle street to wall street uh you know
main street usually goes from wall
street to main street today and went
from
you know wall street to main street
usually it goes main street to wall
street
you know i use these tricks you know
what you know what really made me angry
man
i'm really angry when bitcoin was
reaching like 38 39k
i saw these articles pop up investors
could lose everything in business
these people took out loans and they're
going to lose everything and i'm like
dude i knew what the game was
they wanted you to get scared they
wanted you to sell so they could buy
cheap when it was at like 38 39 you had
people who
finally finally poor people see
cryptocurrency and they're like
i'm gonna buy some of this it's going up
there's real value here well
the fat cats the big firms the big funds
they're like how can we get more of this
but i don't want to spend that much
can we get our our cronies in media to
freak the people out make them think
they'll lose it all so they sell and
then we buy at a premium
and it works they do it over and over
and over again
and now they're reaping the reward of
their own brokenness crazy because
you're not allowed to go out and say
like you can't go out and say hey
sell your bitcoin but an article can be
written about how dangerous it is
so cnbc and their friends they can write
an article saying
it's really bad to buy this don't do it
meanwhile the billionaires are laughing
all the way to the bank and the
working-class people are the ones
getting screwed over tim
you made your point wonderfully i just
want to repackage and restate your point
to me my interpretation of your point i
think america tried
to speak through politics through the
ballot
hey we don't like politicians so we're
gonna elect a reality tv star
yeah then now that they've totally
rejected that
they've turned to okay we're gonna take
money from you to try to express our
dissatisfaction
so it goes from the ballot to the dollar
and the only option left
is the gun though the car those that
what's that saying about the boxes
yeah the ballot box and the cartridge
box or whatever something like that
yeah i'm scared of that now i'm scared
of the idea that
if people are are told that you're not
even allowed to play the game like the
rich people get special privileges
you know what i saw in baron's magazine
they said we need a 30-day
stop on gamestop gamestop stocks because
these poor
unsophisticated investors are going to
be hurt by this
oh yeah i'm sure look some dude takes
his check
he's got 600 bucks he pays his rent he's
got a couple hundred bucks left you know
what his worst case scenario is
when that when this person puts 200
bucks into some stock and it crumbles
he lost 200 bucks i'm sure i'm sure he
or she will be upset about it they will
be upset about it
but with these headphones these hedge
funds are going to lose billions so no
they're not concerned about the poor
unsophisticated investor who might lose
a couple hundred bucks they've never
cared about these people
they're worried about their buddies and
their hedge funds you're gonna lose
billions
and that's it system crumbles you know
tim without government who's gonna make
sure that the stocks don't rise too
quickly
right and and that's that's what exactly
what's happening here and it's so absurd
because we're having people
invest in a company invest in the stock
market something that a government
should see and say
yeah that's great people are investing
and having trust in our big financial
institutions that are usually rigged
against them
but because they're so rigged because
they're so manipulated people are using
those same tricks
and they're they're having a mirror to
this corrupt nasty little witch
that is the financial system and it's
finally seeing itself in its own
reflection and it's saying
oh my goodness i am ugly i created these
rules and these rules are slapping me
upside the head and i'm becoming a lot
uglier as the time goes on
let's talk about this trumpism article
this is an amazing article
from cnn how trumpism explains the
gamestop stock surge
uh spoiler alert it doesn't but uh let's
read anyway from chris seliza
he says that the core of donald trump's
angry populist appeal was and
is this sentiment quote the elites think
they know better than you
they think they can tell you how to live
and what to believe but guess what
we the people are smarter than the
elites let me stop you right there chris
the elites do think that and we the
people
as a decentralized distributed computing
network
are smarter than you it's why communism
doesn't work
because a committee can't figure out how
to distribute resources
better than a decentralized network of
individuals who are seeking the things
they need and want don't get me wrong
i'm not allowed as a fair capitalist i
think there are still problems there
but yeah we see it in computing
a distributed network is better than a
single point of failure
i digress he says trump elucidated this
argument in its purest form at a rally
in north dakota in 2018
when he went on his rift quote i meet
these people they call them the elite
these people i look at them i say that's
elite we got more money we got more
brains
we got better houses apartments we got
nicer boats we're smarter than they are
and they and they say they're elite
we're the elite you're the elite we're
the elite
so i said the other day let's keep
calling these people and let's face it
they've been stone cold losers the elite
the elite so let them keep calling
themselves the elite but we're going to
call ourselves
and remember you are indeed you work
harder but you are indeed smarter than
them
let's call ourselves from now on the
super elite we're the super elite
chris says what made trump's argument so
potent politically speaking
is that he wasn't just calling out the
elites he was saying that the average
joes needed to rise up and actually show
them how wrong they were
that voting for him voting him for him
was the best way to express their anger
and frustration
with the condescension of the alleged
bettors donald trump offered himself up
as a collective middle finger to the
elites and he won
all of which brings me to the current
seemingly inexplicable stock surge of
gamestop
the video game seller that has made its
money over the years thanks to its
location
in malls now from here we get kind of
the point i got to tell you for the most
part
he's bringing up the correct point in
kind of the wrong way it's not
trumpism trump did not create this trump
is a symptom of this
guess what the elites have been saying
we're smarter than you
they have been using revolving door
politics where the people from the
biggest corporations get the jobs in
government overseeing the same company
they just worked for a ceo
or starting wars and selling the bombs
from government back to their friends
those companies
we know what they do and we know the
games they play we know the bailouts
they get
when they fail they they say oh well we
have to save them they're too big but
when mom and pop shops fail
they say sorry too bad why don't you
apply for unemployment maybe six months
we'll kick you a check
that doesn't isn't enough to buy a loaf
of bread more importantly let's even
talk about schools
i'm not a fan of college but they're
they are telling these people your only
choice is to go to college
racking up massive debt for young people
who find no way out the system is
crumbling
the elites have been milking it and
extracting it forever
and it's gotten to the point where
people are saying enough and now the
best part is
the left and the right are both laughing
as this happens but to claim it's
trumpism no you see
trump was the imperfect avatar for
people who felt this anger
but there are people who couldn't agree
with his policies as a man
he couldn't represent this this entity
well enough
with trump gone that entity is now in
its purest form the rage of the people
staring at the elites who have been
stripping out their value and kicking
them down and mocking them
is now just been unleashed and this is
what we get
obi wan kenobi man yes struck him down
that was a being of light
chris the author of this article
actually tweeted it and the number one
response
right now is a picture of ralph with a
flute in his nose
with a thousand five hundred likes uh
right now and i'm i'm reading some of
the replies
and uh a lot of people are just like
what are you
talking about and and you're right he
had a hard time explaining what was
happening so he just
did the laziest thing he could and said
it's just it's all because of this one
guy
trump-ism i want to share this story i'm
not endorsing
what i'm about to share the story but i
live in middle america i live in
tennessee i live in nashville
and the problem with a lot of the media
they live in new york or l.a
they're totally disconnected from real
people i live in nashville right
downtown
it's a very popular bar across street
for me i went and watched sunday
football
there was a young man in the bar wearing
a hat
and he was with a big group of people
and he walked by
to go to the bathroom i said what's on
your hat and it said make politicians
afraid again and that's the sentiment
you have
in the south in tennessee riley
nashville is a relatively uh
liberal city it's had a liberal mayor a
democratic mayor
since like the 1960s or 70s but that
guy's sentiment on his hat that he's
wearing out
in a crowded bar everybody watching
football no one bats an
eye at thinking like that and so
you're right again trump
imperfect avatar but the
if we let people express their anger
through the ballot
it's a lot better than these other
methods that they're going to go to
and if we don't restore some integrity
in our election process
we're just you know we're headed for
civil conflict well i got this quote
this is uh the four boxes of liberty
which we briefly mentioned
they say larry mcdonald a politician
from georgia and former president of the
john birch society
has also been quoted omitting the
caution to use bullets as the last
resort quote
we have four boxes with which to defend
our freedom the soap box
the ballot box the jury box and the
cartridge box
the term is used in newspaper articles
and has been used in a petition of the
supreme court of california
four boxes and derivatives have been
used the name of various websites that
espouse patriotism and the right to bear
arms
i think there's a better quote um that's
probably safer to use
those that make peaceful revolution
impossible make violent revolution
inevitable and that was we talked about
kennedy who said that and so it's
similar when people
soap box and they stand up and say this
must happen and then big tech
bashes them over the head and knocks
them to the dirt well then
they go to the ballot box they cast
their votes then we saw trump bring
people to the jury box
sort of they went to the courts they
tried to they tried and then what we saw
was people storm the capital so it's a
low-grade version and it's scary because
we don't want conflict
we want people to like figure out a path
forward but i tell you right now what
we're seeing with
this this this gamestop wall street
stuff is
populist anger you know what's funny is
there are a lot of establishment
democrat types who are scared of the
word populist
they don't know what it means you're
either a populist or you're an elitist i
understand it's not absolute
but the general idea is for of and by
the people
or for the establishment elites the
cronies the people with the money the
people born in the wealth
the way i look at populism is popular
ideas for the pop for
for the population ideas that the people
want and need so when you have the left
and the right
completely disagreeing on how to
implement the policies to make things
better
but completely agreeing the
establishment is crooked and corrupt and
cheering this on
well then we are seeing some kind of
raw unified force it's not going to be
it's not going to be politically unified
because that's that you know the
politics the political parties the
ideologies
are more of effigies or avatars of this
this ideology or anger now what we're
seeing now is pure rage
like when you see people go out in the
street and riot pure rage there's
nothing there's no rhyme or reason
what we're seeing now with wall street
bets is just digital it's online it's
more strategic
but a lot of people are throwing their
money behind this not expecting it rich
tim do you think because my concern
as a black person is i'm wondering
it's like when i'll have a conversation
with my mother about
all of this and she's so into
democratic politics she's such a barack
ob
i'm not even sure if she fully
understands
what's going on in this country as it
relates to working class versus the
elite my mother was a 30-year factory
worker she is
as working class as it comes but she's
so into democratic politics
that i think she thinks she's an elite
because of the life that i provide her
probably
but i think she thinks she's an elite
and everything to her
or i don't want to speak for but for a
lot of black people everything comes
down to race
trump supporters they're racist so it
doesn't matter
that they stormed the capitol and
confronted white politicians
that was racism that was it's the divide
and conquer
now first i'll i'll say it again because
i think they accomplished nothing by
doing this from the capital
but divide and conquer man when we had
occupy wall street
luke and i met at occupy wall street and
we're like on on you know mere images
idea
we both with the political compass task
test i'm center left luke center right
but we met at the same place because
occupy wall street attracted libertarian
types
right and caps and arco communist
leftists
but something disrupted all that
identity politics
that came in and dominated the
discussion and it pushed out anybody
else who might actually align
and so that that that was divide and
conquer yeah i mean that's why a few
weeks ago we were talking about this and
i'm like
there's going to be a huge
anti-establishment
swell that's going to come after people
realize about
how joe biden is invested in the special
interests that don't serve them that
screw the american people
i think we're seeing the first steps of
this and i think we still have a lot
more to go
a lot more to do and i think this is
going to become more and more prevalent
as we're going to see
this kind of new emergence of a new kind
of occupy wall street populist movement
that's going to be against the
establishment
we're seeing it here i mean i was
telling you it's going to happen a few
weeks ago
i think we're at the beginning of it it
might be the stock thing it might be
another thing but
i i think we're headed towards a lot of
people being extremely discontent with
the current system
realizing it organizing and moving
forward i mean we're seeing almost
close to civil wars breaking out in
places like holland right now
over of course the lockdown issues and
that's only just one issue out of many
issues that people are getting screwed
over with look at vladimir putin saying
in davos
were were in an era that was just like
pre-world war ii
and so we're dangerously close to
something truly traumatic and
devastating in this planet
we talked about this before the mass
printing of money did you know that
somewhere around like 60 to 66 percent
of all u.s dollars were printed in the
past like 10 months
around around that never happened before
and so you have to imagine there's going
to be some rapid and dramatic
instability
or mass divide between the rich and the
poor getting worse
economic inequality leads to serious
economic instability
angry poor people come up come out show
up with pitchforks when they realize
there's no path forward for them
and that if you're gonna you know you
look at some of these places where
there's oligarchy
san francisco is essentially a big tech
oligarch you've got there's so much
human waste littering the streets of san
francisco you heard about
you know about this story san francisco
has their own poop department
it's funny right haha we left no it's
it's serious might
you know you can say that chicago's got
a chicago fire department they got the
chicago pd
and then you can say they got animal
control whatever public services san
francisco has a poop department
they deploy people to clean human waste
off the streets but they have some of
the most well the wealthiest individuals
on the planet
living in the bay area and and working
in these areas how can that be
that is the the divide is massive people
start to realize
that the wealthy elites are rigging the
game to make sure they never lose and
you never win
and then people are going to lose it
yeah they're going to get mad
now this because i'm basically going to
reiterate a point we made earlier
but now looking at how people are like
oh we can play this wall street game too
right nope they'll change the rules on
you yep
glenn greenwald had a very uh you know
very very important tweet today
he said quote pitch perfect expression
of defining neoliberal mentality here
we have an extraordinary political and
cultural conflict involving
intergenerational wealth vast
disparities of power and a deeply
corrupt financial system
and this is all the biden white house
has to say about it and it's
the white house press secretary
responding saying that they have a first
female treasury secretary
so so that that larger and her name is
angela davis
yeah former federal reserve chairman
janet yellen but uh you know
and you know we need it it's we need the
workers of the world to unite
and sure i'm kidding ah short squeeze
these comedies
no it is funny i made that joke the
other day but i'll make it again
uh i just love seeing left and right
come together because the the
identity politics divide was what helped
destroy the unity around
occupy wall street it became a very
leftist thing
when it was actually a very
anti-establishment thing it was like
the big banks were getting bailed out
off our backs and we were suffering
because of it and everybody was mad
about it
and then all of a sudden some kids
showed up and they were like but you're
white
and then all of a sudden the
conservative types who were down were
like this is creepy and weird and left
i remember talking to some 60 year old
couple they were conservatives they were
down there and that american flag
and they were like we don't like what
they're doing to this country and
they're you know extracting our wealth
and all the stuff
but within a couple weeks it was just
far left identity politics progressive
stack
whiteness and you know cis
heteronormativity and things like that
and so is today
perhaps a moment of optimism
oh yeah not for the uh hedge funds
no but for them it's the apocalypse for
us that
because again i am anti-elite that is
probably
our connection is i can't stand elites
and that's despite and a lot of people
say well man you make too much money to
hate elites
no i don't if i made all the money in
the world i would still hate elites
there's a big difference between
you know some somebody who comes up and
makes money and
becomes successful and has lived through
it and the people who are born into
massive billion dollar wealth i'm
talking like the true global elite class
and when you guys say like globalist or
elitist or anything are you talking
about people i
assume you're talking about people with
offshore bank accounts or
um i'm talking about the media
who panders to the elite
everybody on basically mainstream media
the cable news networks
they all pander they're their
spokespersons spokespersons they're
their
departments yes that's what news is
today and then politicians
pander to elites and then the elites who
have
all the money like global bankers that
don't adhere to anything
i'll tell you what elon musk is the
elite of the elite he's the richest guy
on the planet didn't he
yeah no well he's like there's got to be
like saudi kings oh well
putin i think putin is yeah yeah
secretly
okay on the books but he's more wealthy
than bezos yeah no yeah yeah
just happened recently i i don't i like
elon musk
i love him he's tweeting this out he's
promoting it because
he listen i'm not my issue isn't
necessarily with the
you know and probably we should clarify
this too the ultra wealthy
i mean if you make cool stuff if you're
building spaceships and you're making
cool cars and you're doing things that
people like and you're inspiring people
i don't care if you're rich i like the
church i'm happy yeah if you invent the
light bulb and you make people's lives
better please like let you be wealthy
you know like it's awesome
but when you have these politicians who
make money off insider knowledge with
the government
they rig the game the regulators rig the
game and they use the media to trick you
these people are the corruption in our
society that are stealing from us
i'm not saying every politician or every
trader or every fund i'm saying there
are bad ones majority of them if you
remember
last year almost exactly this time there
was an entire scandal
because there was senate hearings where
they talked about kovid
and kovitt coming to the united states
what did
senators politicians do with that
advanced knowledge that was classified
not available to everyone well hold on
hold on you're talking about lefleur and
i think was it purdue it was
was it that was it i think it was them
there was sure yeah
just just specifically they said oh no
that wasn't us because we don't have
control of these things
but i don't care when when you have
nancy pelosi buying tesla stock a month
ago and then joe biden announces he's
going to
switch the entire federal fleet to
electric cars guess who makes millions
and millions of dollars
is it a coincidence that she did this
right before biden was about to come in
and do this
maybe i mean tesla was a good bet so
maybe it was a coincidence
but there's a big problem when you have
your politicians are overwhelmingly
millionaires extremely wealthy what's
like half of congress they're all
millionaires and they don't get paid
that money with a salary
so so where do they get all of that
money that's the big question that
people need to start asking right now
coca-cola
other companies like that they get money
they get bribes
well no i'm sorry they're not called
bribes they're called um lobby
lobby yeah super pac money being
funneled in which you can then
you know what they do is the nonprofits
that's the big trick they'll they'll
someone will say look we can't pay you
the money it's legal but how about
you join the board of our charity and
we'll put 50 million dollars in it
and then you can use that money as an
executive or chairman of this company do
whatever you want
there's ways to give people resources
and money through loopholes and it's the
game they play
so when you see people like um i think
it was biden the biden family had like
some kind of cancer charity
paid a bunch of salaries ran out of
money and then just shuddered
i could be wrong about that so that's
probably wrong but something like that
you see a lot of stories where all of a
sudden some super rich person or some
politician
the clinton foundation i mean yeah how
much money were they bringing in from
who while uh
hillary was secretary of state yeah that
was going on even with mr epstein
involved in that entire mess but that
doesn't get involved
he was bragging about how he started the
clinton global initiative i got kicked
out from their meetings
and banned for for four years when they
were still holding committee meetings
because i made sure to show up and to
ask some serious questions uh they put
me on a do not enter list but
uh without you know saying too many of
the key words here there's a lot of bad
people tied in
to a lot of lobbying efforts that were
directly tied into the clinton global
initiative
we got some breaking news wall street
bets has returned everyone actually
returned a few minutes ago to read it
yeah but i pulled up
this message stay calm a quick
explanation about why the sub
is now private so this is a message from
when they were private now that they are
public we can read this
and here's why they went down ma this is
from a
you geo manus says hello approved
friends the situation here is delegate
obviously with the deletion of our
discord due to tos violations the
moderators here are dealing with an
existential threat to our community
well in the past automated moderation
using bots has been in effect has been
effective for dealing with human users
violating the wall street bet sub tos i
think
i think a has a has been reached where
the quantity and quality of posts
primarily by bot
accounts has likely overwhelmed our
moderator resource
please remember that moderators on
reddit are unpaid volunteers they are
likely working on a way to one prevent
bots from creating ridiculous quantities
of noise
the community up and down voting system
doesn't work when they're endless bots
able to downvote posts
by non-bot accounts similarly
even with eliminating accounts to those
registered in the past 45 days people
have been sitting on thousands
potentially millions of accounts
that were registered in the past purely
in case there was a need to obfuscate
legitimate content and concerns
this has been a tactic used by nation
states for other websites such as
facebook twitter and more
i don't see why powerful groups wouldn't
employ this tactic as well
they say two refresh the rules
surrounding wall street bets etiquette
and three work with reddit to identify
how to safely operate and manage this
subreddit
so remain calm trust in our moderators
trying to dispout any means or offensive
material and check back later
they will find a solution my friends in
2015 reddit was dominated by the donald
it was just massive you go to the front
are you familiar with it right jason
no not really i mean you know you know
like it's a social media website
people post links and then you can give
an up vote or down vote and the more
uploads it gets the higher invisibility
it appears and then eventually go to the
front page the donald is always
dominating
all like r slash all like it's every
subreddit
the donald donald trump memes jokes fun
silliness
they mean donald trump into office that
was the internet discovering their hive
mind powers
with helping donald trump win now
the the fat cat elites were caught off
guard you see with donald trump they got
back
the donald subreddit got first deranked
they were accused of all this craziness
and then they were banned from the front
page they became a restricted or
quarantined subreddit where you had to
like confirm your email
and then bypass some filter to actually
get to the forum to see the memes in the
post about trump
no longer would these pro-trump memes
appear on reddit
unless you sought it out one day the
donald decided
we're at risk of being banned so we're
going to create our own clone called the
donald.win
a separate website that functions the
same they left
this the the community started existing
on its own totally independently and
then four months later
even though the moderators had basically
shut down the reddit
version of it the admins for reddit
banned them
and claimed they were posting hate
speech or some other nonsense
which is weird because they had been
operating entirely in a different
website
so why did they get banned on reddit it
seemed coordinated on purpose
now the donald has become patriots.when
because donald trump is no longer
president
but this was a sign that things were
changing people realized big companies
fat uh you know these these fat cat
elites the establishment elites realized
the power of reddit and influence
how it helped trump win now when you go
to reddit and you go to r slash all
which is just a directory for every post
and their rankings
you'll see like three or four pages of
bernie sanders
ocasio-cortez and all far left that was
the the political people realizing
we need to control the ballot box or
effectively the soapbox
those who would speak and speak up can't
speak up for trump banned them
promote far left and they did and so
you'll often see in the politics tab in
the news tab it's all far left stuff
but what they didn't count on is that
many of these people with this anger
towards the elite establishment were
still functioning but focused on the
finances
and much like they went after donald
trump they
took him a while to realize that donald
was providing trump this resource this
this soapbox
now wall street bets is there and it's
embodied that anger
trump is out it's pure rage at this
point and now they're going after
something outside of politics finances
i think it's only a matter of time
before reddit panics and then does the
same thing prevents this community from
functioning
bans them outright and claims hate
speech what what
concerns me is when someone has a a
forum
and then one of their enemies decides to
make an account and start saying
nasty stuff false flag yeah and then
reddit will be like well there's hate
speech the whole thing's getting the axe
that's what happened with the donald you
see if i were to tell you
that the donald was posting violent
threats against police
would you believe me that that trump
supporters were posting violent threats
against police
that's what they claimed they were doing
they claimed that there were people in
the donald subreddit
threatening cops and when i saw that i
laughed
you gotta be kidding me the people
waving the cop flags
they're the ones starting to ant you go
to the antifa suburbs the anarchist
subreddits
all they do is threaten cops reddit said
well you know
it's threatening people and i was like
bs you know it probably was
far leftists or establishment democrat
types with powerful interests
could very easily just go to the donald
create an account and then post
something nasty
and that's it and then they submit
themselves they make the post
log into a different account and submit
it to red and say hey look hate speech
hey look a threat yep
and it happens a lot and uh elon musk by
the way just tweeted quote even discord
has gone
crow poor so kropor
and and of course he's responding to
discord taking down wall street bets
because of alleged hate speech what's
crochet
um thank you c-r-uh c-o-r-p-o that's
what he got corporal
you can't you can't let the people rise
up man you can't let the hive gain power
so they stopped donald trump donald
trump was memed into existence man i
mean i know he explained i mean like the
presidency
yep i watched it happen as a mine's
admin it was so
insidious the memes were just funny the
jokes and everyone shared it and it
worked and it worked
the pepe the frog wall street that's
trump's hair
yeah this may not be connected but i
just want to throw it out there just ask
the question
does the drudge reports pivot connect to
any of this at all
i don't know that's weird though right
the drudge used to be like
right wing and now they're not yeah well
they turned they they were very
pro-trump they turned against trump so
did uh rupert murdoch and all of his
institutions
uh especially the daily mail especially
a lot of people accuse fox news of doing
this obviously not sean hannity and
tucker carlson but the other kind of
reporting that happened there but there
was one definitive switch where
any kind of support in the institutions
went away
dramatically and some people said that
was because of personal arguments that
donald trump had
with uh you know rupert murdoch so
that's also a possibility here that we
have to understand
so we gotta uh so i i gotta tell you man
i'll say the unity check this out this
is on uh wall street bets they say we
gotta shout out bros
gme aoc tweets gotta admit it's really
something to see wall streeters with a
long history of treating our economy as
a casino
complain about a message board of
posters also treating the market as a
casino
i love it props aoc let's bring on this
unity
i will absolutely stand side by side
with all of the leftists and right wing
whoever
if we're if we're talking about the
establishment elites and their
manipulative games to steal our money
i'll take it i'll take the win we can
argue the politics and policy stuff
after the fact
but this is what they were most afraid
of the left and the right realizing that
as working-class people as the non-elite
as the non-establishment they got more
in common
like mitch mcconnell and nancy pelosi
are basically part of the same political
party as far as i'm concerned
there's no question about it i i'm i
still think this identity politics thing
is
really strong and maybe that's just me
as a black person because i know the
influence of black lives matter
and that will potentially stand in the
way
of people awakening from my community to
like
hey no no because that that's all i've
been trying to promote
probably my entire career is like hey
man working class people you have
far more in common than you have
in contradiction or in conflict with
each other if you can
just get past the race thing you'll see
you guys are natural ally we're natural
allies
but they've used this race thing so
effectively
you know the whole democratic platform
seems to be you know pull that lever
for white people it's pull that lever
and no one can call you racist
and for black people pull that lever and
no one can call you a [ __ ] or an uncle
tom
and it's worked it blows my mind you
know what that's their platform you know
what really blew my mind is when the rnc
had uh they had a few speakers come up
who are black
yeah and then the left started calling
them tokens yes and i'm like you
complain they're not diverse enough
so they say okay and they put forth some
black speakers and then you say they're
tokenizing them i'm like there's no
winning is there
no matter what they do they're racist i
don't even like the word black and white
because like we're not
me and you aren't white or black you're
you have like an auburn
colored skin i have like a pinkish skin
and like
so these ancient words of like diver
diversion like they're like look at that
person that's
the black it's like they were never
black to begin with i understand divine
pigmentation is
different where are you guys at on
religion i'm a christian
i was raised a christian i believe in
principles from the bible and and that's
i i
i've written and talked about i don't
want to be defined as black i want to be
defined as a christian
patriotic american that's what i want my
identity to be
that's that's funny but you're not
allowed you know what i mean like you
can identify as basically anything you
want except for that
that's the bigoted that's the wrong you
can identify as
whatever i think jesus was tight i think
that the church has like
built a business around no question yeah
no ques but
but i think so much of our identity is
tied to politics now
and to me i've never wanted to be judged
on that and
for for black people i don't understand
to me racist slave owners 400 years ago
said your skin color is the most
important characteristic you have
and it limits your freedom and now here
we are 400 years later
and black people are saying my skin
color is the most important
characteristic i have
and it limits my freedom right it's your
christianity
in that christ is means anointed so
to be anointed by the christian means
the anointed one
and so they called jesus the christ
because he was anointed by god but we're
all anointed by god this energy
is flowing through our bodies and we're
able to create with it
you know these we can touch each other
yeah
and that's what we should be focused on
one of the things anyway well
i think we're people you know what i
mean and it's i remember growing up and
rolling my eyes as a teenager
when i would hear things like race is
not relevant because we're all human
beings we all bleed the same and i'm
like i know i get it racism is bad
now i'm older and they're saying the
opposite the left is like no race is
everything
don lemon goes on tv and says he wants
to know that everybody sees him as
a black man and that's you know and i'm
like it's all bs
and i wish i could say what i really
think but
he's lying because that's not what's
most important to him
i actually and i'm not trying to be his
sexual identity trumps his racial
identity
and you like in terms of what he talks
about and what he
you know what he's most passionate about
right right right is and again i've
asked people all the time
and and this is a co if you had a choice
i asked friends of mine
i said let's say that there was some
deal where the government came down and
said hey look
you're either gonna have to choose being
heterosexual or black
which one are you gonna stick with
that's i was thinking about that earlier
and so i i said
i said so go ask don lemon that question
and see what the answer gets
he's it's not going to be black and i'm
like so
why are you priority if you're why are
you prioritizing blackness when it's not
your most
important characteristic and again so if
god came down
and said what i i'm christian
i'm american and i'm heterosexual all
that would come before
black in terms of if i want to hold on
to certain things
i want to hold on to being christian i
feel incredibly lucky to be born in this
country
so i want to be here in america yeah and
then i i tend to like
women so i want to hold on to being a
headache i i think when it comes to
politics
you've got you've got high functioning
individuals i'm not trying to be mean or
disrespect anybody
but you've got people who are more
logical less emotional and you've got
people who are more emotional less
logical
and so somebody who's not particularly
logical they they judge a book by its
cover
it's an emotional response they can look
at you and see hey
you look very different from me and what
my family looks like then they can
manipulate and exploit that
they can say oh you must be racist so
these are these are low functioning
people who are easily exploited by
racial politics whereas high functioning
people are like
i don't know people it's merit it's hard
work it's
what you choose to do some people are
smarter some people are dumber some
people are stronger some people are
taller some people are shorter
everybody's different you know we have
to respect those differences but
there's there's bigger differences
between like there's there's
a you know a white dude who's six foot
seven and there's a white dude who's
five
foot three and there's a bigger
difference between them than like you
and me
race doesn't even play that big of a
role i've asked people all the time if
they're even aware
that there is a height bias in all of
society
the taller you are the more successful
you tend to be yeah and
you know it it's there's height
privilege that
oh but they play that they call it
low-hanging fruit for a reason
no the the the the leftists have all of
that like the the super critical race
it's not critical it's the critical
theory people they've got they've got
like thin
privilege they've got tall privilege
they got all of it
heightest i think is the name for it but
but again you bring up a very important
point if
if the most important and the most
interesting thing about you if you think
it's something
superficial you're not interesting
you're not important at all
you're you're divulging from the actual
thing that makes you special and that's
you as a unique human being and you're
either a very bad one or a very good one
or in between but you decide that and
it's not superficial it's based on
your morals your virtues and in your
actions that people
don't care about anymore because they
care about only how you look which is
ridiculous
and dumb height it does have some
advantages if you're
if you're your legs are longer you can
run away from
hungry lines faster you can reach the
fruit that's higher up on the tree
easier
if your skin is dark you have some
advantages if you're trying to hide at
night
it's harder to see you if you have dark
skin doesn't damage me
the way that yeah yeah you can take more
sun damage um i glow
you don't get my skin like almost glows
at night from like a little bit of
ambient money
so i'll i'll jump out so there are
inherent advantages to the way we look
in our shapes and our sizes but that
doesn't mean that we're better
or worse well look look it's pros and
cons a tall person's not going to be
able to hide as effectively than a short
person exactly but they could
potentially run faster
so it's really just you know the way
i've always been
you know growing up with my family who
of course you know it's been mentioned a
million times
in my various shows is mixed race it
it's that
everybody's dealt to have a hand of
cards when they're born
and you might have a bad hand but you
can still win
you watch a poker game where dudes got
like two seven off suit and he still
wins
yeah because he played it right if the
blinds are high you got to go all in
yeah well it's it's about
it's about strategy you may not have the
best hand in the world but if you play
your cards right you can get ahead
or the other thing i like is we can't we
can't we can't control the win but we
can't adjust our sails
so some people look in the mirror they
look at themselves and they think it's
unfair i'm wrong and that's on them
man it's on you you can succeed if you
choose we talk about
um like what would you call like
familiarity bias which seems to be a
real thing like if you're surrounded by
a bunch of people that look like you
then other people that don't look like
you are
are out different and so there's this
inherent like fear of the unknown
that seems to be prevalent in our
consciousness for some reason
so like i spent time in south america
and it was noticeable i stood out like
the people had darker skin i looked like
a for
like a foreign person and they would all
like look at me like oh that's different
and i noticed it firsthand then and then
you see the thing is people
the first thing they notice is what you
look like so we try very hard and we've
succeeded very much so
in the past 100 years to realize there's
more to people than just what we see
that's why we say don't judge a book by
its cover
but now we have this new group of
critical race theorists that are saying
no no we must judge
the book by its cover not only that
they're burning books so it's regressive
it's not program progress they're
literally reactionaries who are trying
to bring us back to the way things used
to be
the left likes to call the right
reactionary because
the the phrase comes from the french
revolution when you had
the reaction to the revolution so those
that wanted to maintain the status quo
were called reactionary
my friends what's what is the status quo
in this country how long have we had
civil rights in this country so so you
want to tell people how old you are
what's your i'm 53.
so you you seriously remember like when
things were substantially more racist in
this country
yes and my parents certainly reminded me
what was it like
uh look interracial dating used to be a
huge deal when i grew up huge that
someone
dated outside their race the whole all
the kids talked about the parents talked
about it baba
it was a big deal if you lived in a
neighborhood
uh outside if you black person lived in
a white it was a big deal
none of that stuff is and first of all i
the obstacles that i face i don't think
were anything in comparison to my
parents i was
raised with no excuses
you've been put in position and keep in
mind and i was not put
i was put in a great position because i
got two supportive parents but i grew up
poor
me in 1984 my senior year of high school
me and my dad lived in a 400 square foot
one bedroom apartment in the ghetto but
there were no excuses there was no my
dad was a booker t
washington cast your bucket down
do for yourself when i lived with him my
senior
high school he the irs had taken
everything from him he
hadn't done well with his taxes or
whatever but he was a small businessman
in the inner city most of my life
and but there were no excuses i tried to
quit my college football team and i was
on scholarship
and both of my parents said good luck
with the rest of your life if you're
dumb enough to quit that
free college education and good luck
jason and so
there's just no excuses and i really
can't i look back at my child it was
awesome weren't you just talking about
how you made a bunch of money in stocks
yeah like you're kind of well off and
your mom thinks she's an elite now
she certainly lives like one but i mean
i mean i mean this
as a sign of the utmost respect that
you're talking about how you grew up you
were in the high school in the ghetto in
this tiny apartment
and that sounds like you're doing really
well man yeah no i've been doing well
for a while but
my high school was working class where i
lived with my dad was
poor but anyway i
had i have lived the american dream
my parents divorced when i was young
i've lived in the hood i've lived in
working class
suburbs per se and i have worked my way
up the la my first job
in college was five dollars an hour this
is what this is the point i'm trying to
get to just to go back to where
you know where where i was at i grew up
hearing these stories from my from my
family as well especially from my mom
who experienced
growing up in you know before the civil
rights she was a little she was a little
kid before there was even civil rights
law
1976 67 civil rights act before loving v
virginia
so my mom's side of the family like my
mom's side of the family
literally was illegal this was back when
before the supreme court ruled that
interracial
relationships were allowed so i think
about that i think about where we've
progressed to right
to a point where we're now saying don't
judge people based on their race these
things aren't
important we need to be human and what
do we get the critical race theorists
have reacted to that racial revolution
the realization that we're human beings
they're reactionary they want to bring
us back to that old status quo of the
past several thousand years
where people immediately judged everyone
based on their race that is the old
status quo we fought so hard to get past
so that you could have somebody who's a
black man who who grew up working class
and also in bad neighborhoods and became
very successful
that you aren't judged by the by the
color of your skin but by the content of
your character
to me that's the stories i grew up with
from my family who told me how bad it
was
and how we won i'm a little kid and i
hear the story oh we won that fight's
over
now they've come back and they're trying
to take us back in time to the stone age
i'm not okay with that i keep thinking
like there are differences
in genetics fine whatever that's
maybe it's intentional on earth you know
you get more sun if your ancestors got
more sunlight
your skin will get darker to handle the
sunlight if you
i think that uh asian people are their
eyes are like more slanted because they
or their ancestors lived in the high
winds of the plains of like michaelian
plains so they had to squint a lot
i don't know if that's i don't know i'm
trying to figure out why that it could
be it could be
just nothing well it's got to be
something that caused our bodies to
shape
it differently like i think the really
light-skinned people were they either
worked and lived at night the aryans
i've heard up north
and they lived up north with blinding
sun uh the the snow so they would blend
into their background more
no they cover it up and they it didn't
matter
there was all sorts of possibilities but
they're real and like our genetics are
real more
you have more melanin in your skin i
don't know if you inherently have more
melanin in your skin
and that's why it's darker or uh
pigmentation wise
but it's real it's like genetically okay
fine deal with it
but like it doesn't mean that we're
better or worse than each other we're
you know
we're people yeah and and we fought
really hard to get to that point where
we can
break bread together and live together
and respect one another and it is now
coming from the left to break us back
down and send us back to the
to you know every six mo i your point
that it
now is coming from the left is one that
i've been pondering
i had think that it's
always been the left that the
the left the democratic party everybody
says
that lyndon johnson somehow had this
conversion and he stopped being racist
and he signed the civil rights act of
1964
and the democratic party all just
changed and they love black people
i don't believe that i believe that
tactics change that the agenda
stays the same but people adapt
different tactics
and that's why last week and i got a lot
of heat for this for saying
hey black lives matter antifa they
operate the way the kkk
operated the kkk was started in the
1860s after the emancipation
proclamation
it was the enforcement arm of the
democratic party the agenda
was to impose force people to support
democratic politicians
politics and to keep
black people in a substandard condition
here in america
i don't think things changed in the
1960s i think the tactics changed
you could no longer lynch people
technology basically eliminated that
because now people have phones in their
homes you can call it the kkk comes to
your house and tries to pull you out of
there you can call the police and they
you can't lynch people anymore it's too
easy to get caught we started
prosecuting people
so we no longer lynch people but we do
bully them
through social media campaigns you have
black lives matter
antifa they will come to your home and
intimidate you they'll take instead of
and take your way of living to instead
of burning crosses we have burning
buildings
and then if you look at the policies
that the democratic party
adopted from the 60s on the elimination
and the destruction of the black family
intentional
intentional in my and and so basically
we've infused
black people if you just go look at it
we've infused
black people with a racist mindset an
anti-black mindset instead of the kkk or
white racist person being most likely to
use the n-word
it's now us instead of the kkk
killing us it's now us killing each
other in
record numbers in our own communities
it's it's now instead of us putting out
blackface music or
entertainment instead of white people
doing that
we now have rappers that do that and put
out these
very negative stereotypes about black
people and we
celebrate this as our culture we have
been
turned into our own worst enemy we
act and have adopted the mindset of the
kkk
and we're doing it at the behest of the
democratic party and i'm sorry if that
pisses
i think it's true you know that the
black lives matter website
said one of their goals was to disrupt
the nuclear family they're doing it's
other races uh
i don't know if are we is it technically
are we different races i don't know if
that's the right word to use but
whatever but like
i hate white they say uh the white
knight
concept of a guy that's like i side with
the feminists so i
do i dislike men like they're turning
men against men in that sense or
um i should be guilty because of my skin
color like they're trying to turn me
against that that
race or whatever yeah no no no
democratic party hide and conquer
it's it's just about make people
racially conscious
so that they have negative stereotypes
to people based on race
i don't think you know there's a lot of
like alt-right people who think that
they want white people to dislike
themselves or something no i think it's
just divide and conquer they don't care
who hates you as long as people don't
like each other
that way the heat is taken off the
establishment they don't want i think it
started with occupy wall street
because i remember my first real
encounter with the critical race theory
crazies was at occupy
and it was like after i saw
conservatives and libertarians down
there and i was like wow that's crazy
but then it went so they went straight
up progressively it really started with
um 911 where they turned us against the
middle eastern people no that unifying
color well the unified amer
white-skinned people against dark
skinned it wasn't about race though it
kind of was it was about religion they
were like muslims are dangerous
put a but then it was like who's muslim
primarily in the world is people in the
middle east
the target of 9 11 after so after this
was
saddam hussein and the taliban yeah but
they made us afraid of
of a certain people first like
xenophobia it was a target of a country
and the idea of terrorism
they unified this country against its
perceived enemy terror
and so there was no heat on the
establishment george w bush's approval
rating skyrocketed
this country came together in anger in a
direction the establishment could
weaponize but
we didn't let me ask you this before you
go
are you sure it's any different and i'm
asking i don't know
the japanese were responsible or we say
were for pearl harbor
what 9 11 they flew planes into the
building
i can't be mad at the middle east people
or
saddam hussein or osama bin laden
for flying osama bin laden for flying
those planes into
america i can't be mad at the japanese
for for pearl harbor
i mean well those were actually
organized groups and
the anger was pointed at the problem is
when the japanese american civilians
got thrown in tournament camps because
the japanese empire
so like if osama bin laden or whoever it
was destroyed some buildings as a small
group of terror
to go after civilians in our own country
in response i thought i think was
heavy-handed
sure but for the most part if the
establishment can unify this country
but as a weapon against thing you know
the enemies to empower the establishment
like
they wanted to go to war in the middle
east for a variety of reasons
there's strategic positioning around
iran then you've got qatar turkey
pipeline there's always an excuse for
what's going to rally americans but
something started changing
with mass media when we had syria and
the gas attack
you had a lot of people on the left
saying they didn't believe it they
didn't believe the propaganda against
assad
and then you had people on the right
saying there's got to be a red line it
wasn't necessarily the right of the left
we're at a point now where they can't
unify us
because we're mad at them and every
attempt they make to point the finger at
someone else
it just comes right back to the
establishment elites because we've
figured it out
the mask has come off the curtain has
fallen or like hey wait a minute
hey wait a minute you've been
manipulating us this whole time
you listen 911 was was a nightmarish
scenario for this country
nightmare never forget and so was pearl
harbor
and what did they do they took us at our
weakest when we were scared when we were
angry and we wanted justice
and many of us were emotional i was just
a kid and they said it was that guy who
did it go kill him
and we said yes sir for america we will
have justice
and then we realized it was fake it was
a lie they tricked us
they sent us overseas this nation to
iraq and afghanistan for what there were
no weapons of mass destruction they
weren't involved it was a lie
they manipulated us at our weakest
moment that's what they do and now
people are finally realizing
we are done with this and so are we so
they elected a reality tv guy well right
but also but
i want to ask this because and this is
where
i disagree with a lot of people i think
the siege of the capital is the most
overplayed thing
this alleged insurrection where i never
saw one of these trump supporters
that i've seen draw a gun and and so
i've watched nancy pelosi and mitch
mcconnell
basically stand up and and they're
pulling it off oh my god did you see
the trump people they tried to overthrow
the government
all because we're protecting you and
people are going for it yeah
because i'm looking at i'm like hey man
i watched all of 2020 people burn down
buildings
loot riot kill police officers
and they're acting like this thing at
the capitol
was worse than what i saw in minneapolis
kenosha atlanta
l.a the stuff that's going on in new
york in chicago 9 11.
and i'm like hey man i've watched the
video i keep looking for this crazy
insurrection
and i just don't see it you remember
remember the officer i think it was in
vegas he was just
out because there were riots or uh and
and so he was just standing around
and so one of these riders is walking
away and just turns and fires two shots
and keeps walking
hits him in the head paralyzes the guy
why
yet they don't care about this they
don't care about this right it's because
the centralized authority another
problem about having like
congress people but people are going for
this capital thing it's because the
people at the capitol that got most
affected by it are the politicians yeah
and it's because that all that power
centralized in these 450 people
that it's so vulnerable that if those
guys get messed with the whole system
shutters
they don't what happened to them i think
tim just said he's from the south side
of chicago
i've been in some neighborhoods in
indianapolis where helicopters
gunshots kids are traumatized on a
nightly basis
nancy pelosi had some people in a wolves
uniform
coming to the capitol and she's acting
like she's a kid on the south side
that she's been traumatized i tell you
man i i
used to spend a lot of my time covering
conflict around the world you know i
worked for vice i went to egypt
i was in ukraine it's in venezuela and i
always had people ask me like did you
train for this like it's got to be scary
people are shooting i was in ferguson
people were shooting live ammo
and i was like oh no no i'm just from
the south side of chicago
i was like dude i went to uk i went to
ukraine during the start of the euro my
dad movement which eventually led to the
ousting of yanukovych
and you know there was mods of cocktails
they were guns i got surrounded by
people i was in turkey
i went to one neighborhood where a bunch
of guys surrounded me pushed me up
against the wall and held a molotov
cocktail to my face
and i'm cool as a cucumber man i'm like
people are like aren't you scared
we were filming when that happened too
i'm not trying to brag i'm just like
dude in chicago
you want to talk about growing up with
like dude high school fights where i'm
from people had guns and so
people would scream and run and we were
laughing as we were running from the
guns
it's like it's just you grow up in this
man dude if you're black
and my we're we've been conditioned we
go to nightclubs
where we have to go through metal
detectors to get inside the nightclub
commonplace almost every black knight
metal detector is to make sure you
weren't carrying a gun and so we've been
conditioned to normalize this
but but i'm just looking at this capital
thing and i'm going
there are kids in communities that are
hearing gunshots every night
their cousins have been killed their mom
uncles somebody's been shot he's ganged
up and these kids are traumatized on a
daily basis
and no one cares but the cat but nancy
pelosi
oh my god she hid under a desk or
something it's like
it's it's look it's bad it is but you
know ian's right
it was it's the nucleus when that got
hit it shook the whole system
but i'll tell you why the establishment
elites the people with power the
politicians
they don't care about you so they don't
know when the they're not there they're
not getting
they're not getting their windows shut
up tell you why it's true it's true but
there's some truth there
just like true when when i got here
today you told me
that there were no police basically
yeah and that was something i didn't
know welcome to the wilderness man yeah
that was so so to clarify there are cops
but i tried explaining this to my my
very lefty friends who grew up in cities
i'm like you realize people who live in
the middle of nowhere
don't have a local police department to
rush to you like you've got to take care
of yourself
for me that's no big deal i grew up on
the south side of chicago where you
pretty much can't trust the cops anyway
to do anything for you and
to to be fair a lot of them are bad cops
but also a lot of them are overwhelmed
with how crazy things can get
so i get it and i've always just been
like i gotta rely on myself
but to the point about pelosi i think
look
they know what's going on in chicago
they've not experienced it
i don't think they care i think they
hear about it in the news and they're
like yeah well what else is new
and then to them never experiencing it
finally having you know i tell you when
i saw some of these videos of like the
bumbling and bewildered
you know older folks walking through the
capital and then i see these people
panicking
and like ducking and hiding i'm like
really
like you've got these pictures of the
politicians and they're like laying down
hiding
and i'm like these people for the most
part weren't armed now i do think there
was some real danger because some of
these people seem to have been really
nuts
really really crazy many of them i
believe most were probably just
befuddled
like the cops opened the door in several
instances and people just walked in with
little flags and didn't know what was
going on
i was surprised to see you know there's
this meme it's really funny it shows the
p these politicians laying down and
hiding
with gas masks on and says these are the
people who send your kids to go fight in
wars and die
yep and look the other way as bodies
pile
up in cities all over america but if a
white cop
kills somebody black the whole country
shuts down everybody takes a knee
at arenas and stadiums all across the
country
and george floyd becomes
the mlk of this generation and and
and i just want to add here i had a
cousin that i helped raise
that i helped that i loved i paid for
his funeral killed by the police killed
by sheriffs in indianapolis
i am not uncaring
about police brutality but
i'm also not a liar that is not
again my father never left the hood
built a brand new house in the hood he
carried a 38
he had a alarm system at his home and it
wasn't to protect himself from the
police
let's quit telling that lie and the
masterpiece lounge
in the inner city of indianapolis my
favorite place on earth my dad's bar
we weren't sitting around oh my god hope
i can make it home hope the police don't
kill me on the way home
when somebody when a man walked you to
your car
woman in my dad's bar it wasn't to
protect you from the police
it was from the dudes that walked them
streets in that neighborhood
i i'll never forget the la my dad died
and i threw a big party at his bar the
masterpiece lines just work
my brother wanted to keep the bar and i
was like jim we ain't built for this we
not like
my father we we can't and we're closing
it up at 3am
and right outside the door the back door
two dudes are beating the living hell
out of another dude bottles upside
head and all and i can remember i told
my brother i said you think we built to
run this business
when this is going on every night this
ain't us we too soft for this
you know i grew up i grew up with some
really bad stories about cops i've had
cops kick the door into my apartment
at gunpoint i've been while covering a
protest in chicago surrounded by cops at
gunpoint
a lot of just really nasty stuff yeah i
was there yeah that's right
luke was filming it they put the gun to
my head after i took out the people
that's a common occurrence so we dealt
with this i was in chicago
and i'll tell you this though i've had
some bad experiences but i've also been
saved from a mugging by a group of cops
and a lot of people i guess you don't if
you don't experience these things you
don't really get it
but i was in uh i was on north side of
chicago and i don't know how that was i
was like 20 years old
i was i'm broke hanging out with my
friends crossing the street
and some dude he comes up to me and he
starts basically threatening me
telling me i got to give him he asked me
for my money can i have your money man
come on
let me get your money i'm just trying to
do the right thing and i laugh i'm like
i don't got any money dude i was like
i'm a 20 year old dude i'm broke
and so he kept pressuring me he had a
guy following about 15 feet behind
basically a spotter something goes wrong
his buddy comes up and helps him
i pull out my empty wallet literally
nothing but an id in it and then he's
like i know you got money in your shoe
i know you got money you think i'm
stupid i got a knife and then i started
laughing i'm just laughing i'm like what
is this guy gonna do is he gonna like
frisk me i don't got money
all of a sudden it's like it's like a
split second i have no idea what
happened
i just get like kind of pushed to the
side and this big dude in this overcoat
grabs the guy by the front of his collar
spins him around and
slams him into a fence and screams in
his face spit flying
not in my town and then out of nowhere
two uniform b cops are behind me and i'm
like
what is going on they pull me aside like
you okay sir and i'm like yeah yeah
they cuffed the guy i think his
information they were like we've been
watching these dudes
we're we're you know we're tracking i'm
trying to see we didn't know what they
were up to we're glad we were here and i
was like
cool it's like wow and i i have more bad
experience and positive ones to be
completely honest
but that was an amazing experience where
they shook my hand told me you know
everything cool you're all right have a
good day sir we caught him in the act we
don't even need you as a witness
and i was like all right that was it
turns out the guy actually lived on the
south side not too far from me by the
way so it's a funny story
but i think people you know get too much
of the negative propaganda when it comes
to cops
because it's shocking and it it it plays
well it gets shares
world view by anecdotes yeah rather than
data
facts and we have an anecdote driven
society and that's very dangerous
and i don't understand why congress our
lawmakers haven't focused in
the biggest spreader of misinformation
disinformation
information that makes people via it's
it's twitter it's not parlor
yeah and they never go after twitter
it's i don't jack dorsey to me
is one of the five most powerful people
in america
who is he did we vet this guy is he's
not an elected official
but he gets to decide public discourse
the tone of it
who gets to speak whose voice gets
amplified the guy has
an incredible amount of power and i
don't know who he
is and neither i don't think most of
america knows who he is
it seems ridiculous that we're shutting
down
parlor and no one's looking at twitter
too my buddy posted a video that has uh
it's a clip of anthony fauci saying
masks you don't need masks are not
needed they
they don't do what you think they do
they give people a false sentence from
security from like i think
end of march or april and then facebook
click masked it and said this has
partially
false information and ben was like what
the
[ __ ] was wrong it was out of context it
was just a clip but it was he was
very clear saying you don't need them
they they don't give you the benefits
well they do gold
it's an old video so his position has
changed he was emphatic and he's been in
the industry for 70 some or
he's 80 70. so he's been doing this for
decades and for him to not know
after 30 years of serving in this in his
position to not know that masks are
effective or not well now he wants you
to wear two of them yeah three seconds
like cnbc wants you to wear three of
them so he spent 20 or 30 years studying
this stuff and then within eight months
he completely did it
a 180 degree turn wasn't there a meme
where like
you said someone's smothering their gram
with a pillow yes that's the only way to
put that
is these enough matte are these enough
masks all right all right everybody
let's jump to super chats and take all
comments
if you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe hit that notification
bell
and more importantly we're gonna have a
bonus segment i shouldn't even call it
bonus i'm any more just members only
content over at timcast.com
so we're trying to do more talk about
more stuff
more issues and things that typically we
get kind of
hard to talk about because of censorship
on social media so timguez.com is really
our opportunity to do whatever we want
we're going to be filming some more
behind the scenes stuff as well and
uh we're going to oh i shouldn't say too
much but we're going to do some on the
road stuff
talking about guns and and survival
stuff
just to you know just to get more more
content show you behind the scenes stuff
i mentioned this as we go to our first
super chat
because they'd be ragging on us all
right petty says
hearing you guys talk about guns is
almost as frustrating as hearing ian
talk about things other than
how banking is evil you'll catch up
eventually though
all right all right listen i've never
pretended to be an expert
i always say like i'm a new gun guy like
you know what i mean like it's only been
just over a year not even a year for me
so far we're all learning and we're open
to learning more we're not always right
to fact check everything yourself and
another thing there is a gun culture in
person which is absolutely incredible
and amazing when you're on the range and
you meet certain people
but online especially when it comes to
people's opinions about guns holy cow
watch out
i don't know anything i'm a noob i'm a
novice uh compared to all the cr
i mean the best things i could do is
literally post uh you know something
that i'm doing with firearms
i'll get so many critiques and thank you
i i'm willing to get better i'm willing
to listen to them some of them are right
some of them are wrong
but i'm willing to get better anytime so
thank you for your constructor of
criticism
so i'll say this too mr petty all right
yeah
now we're we're you know we here on tim
cast iron well we're tough as nails so
you can criticize us all day and night
i actually try to read the very critical
uh messages about us too
i won't shy away from them you know
recently we did a segment where we
talked about the jacobin magazine cover
with joe biden as jesus
and we thought it was serious i think
that's mostly my fault because you know
jack and luke couldn't even see it yeah
and i took it seriously and later on we
were like oh that was satire wasn't it i
got roasted
i got roasted and i deserve it and kyle
kalinski did a segment it was really
funny i laughed
he's like oh tim tim tim tim what are we
gonna do with you and i was laughing i
was like you got me
you got me i screwed up i thought it was
funny i'll own up to it man
but i would just say to the people who
uh we've got a lot of comments about
like you guys know what you're talking
about have on
some expert we're trying and i think a
lot of people online
you should uh you know flies with honey
not vinegar you know what i mean well i
appreciate the constructive criticism
thank you uh we're always uh we always
could be better
i want to have an expert on dreams on
the show so where we are
i had some crazy dreams today like super
vivid i thought i was there
what time like four in the afternoon
i don't remember i was asleep all right
all right let's read super chat we got
jesse pyle saying jason whitlock is the
man
fact outstanding insight and journalism
much wisdom and looking forward to your
group's discussion
right on well we had the discussion
earlier super chat these are from
earlier
a lot of people were pointing out the
wall street bets back up we did see that
eventually
gareth green says pool sunbae or pool
appa if you prefer
i am the heir of a wealthy family and i
have been personally hurt and offended
by leftist populist rhetoric for my
entire life
i always thought the rhetoric of the
occupy movement was hate and bigotry
against me
i get it i do and i think there's too
much where like
we need to clarify what we mean and what
we're really mad at so when the left
says tax the rich
what they only sometimes clarify and
should do more often is that they're
referring to the exploitation the people
stripping value from the working class
not those that genuinely do good and
earn it and when we're talking about the
elites and stuff i pointed out like i
actually think elon musk is really cool
i don't think he's perfect i think he's
done some really dumb stuff but i don't
think
you know my concern is are you ripping
people off are you evil
are you stealing from people and hurting
them if you're a good person who helps
people and they lift you up for it
that's awesome
i think that's great my problem with
elites let's take let's stay in the
sports lane
lebron james i have a problem with him
he's an elite
and i don't think he says things
publicly that he actually believes i
think he
caters his comments to how they'll be
will they be popular over twitter
and i see so many people on the left or
uh these influencers say things i'm like
is that what you would tell your child
the same thing you're saying over
the excuses you're making uh the advice
you're giving is that the same thing you
would tell your child
i just think they're they're just too
dishonest i once heard
someone on the left say that uh
during this whole black lives matter
deal that
they that he and his wife had forbid
his 17 18 year old son from driving
anymore out of fear that
he would be assassinated by the police
and and so we make him take uber
because we're so afraid of and i'm like
are you being serious
what what city do you live in and the
person lived in houston
and i was like go check the stats 17
year old black boys
if they're gonna die by gun violence go
see if it's the police
or if it's not another 17 year old black
kid and then tell me
so are you forbidding your black son
from hanging out with black kids
but you're going to forbid him from
driving out of fear of the cop it's that
kind of dishonest
rhetoric hyperbolic rhetoric that i find
defensive
and it makes me despise these people
yeah and it never deals with the root
cause of the problem
it's never going to fix the problem
because it obfuscates it so people don't
even understand the reality of it
very and again and i've had bad
experiences with the police one
in particular but even in my bad
experience with the police and it was
bad it went on for about 30 minutes in
south carolina
25 years ago compliance got me out of it
got me home in bed to be pissed off at
them
nothing happened to me yeah comply i
have
friends who are police officers just
comply
and again complying and killing them
with kindness
because i i've i like to drive fast i no
longer drive but when i did i drove
really fast
if i had a chance to go over 100 miles
an hour i went over 100 miles an hour
pulled over many times i got out of so
many tickets just killing police
officers with kindness
just killing them they'd be mean to me
and i would still
officer i'm so sorry it was so stupid of
me to do that
i get a warning ticket i get it most of
the time i get a one
it's incredible people don't get it man
that cops are people who are at work
like how would you feel if you're at
work and then someone did something that
bothered you you'd be like
or like they're breaking the rules
you're like dude i'm doing this thing
here you are you got to be like ah dude
i'm sorry i'm not trying i know you're
frustrated you probably want to go home
see your kids have a burger last thing
you want to do is be dealing with some
smart
some smart aleck mouthing off at you i
see these videos where people are like
shouting their rights at them
and i'm like i get it i respect it i
would never do that
i just i just try to be tactful and and
you know understand the circumstances
or if my goal with anybody
if it's hey i want to get a phone number
from a girl i'm going to kill her with
kindness i'm not going to tell her i
have a right to her phone number
uh if i want to get out of a situation
with the police with a
warning ticket or not getting arrested
i'm gonna
you're the best way to do it is kill
them with kindness i try to always
make their life better like even if
they're screwing me over or being cruel
to me i'm
i just think like okay when this is over
i want them to have a better life so
i'll
here's what's comical ian is that many
people believe
that the police see your white skin and
just go oh my god sir i'm sorry for
pulling you over
uh hey just slow it down a little bit
buddy go ahead they have no idea the
police
just because of the job they're pretty
much a-holes to anybody they can get the
most
pissed off a cop has ever been in me is
when i was on my phone in my car
he drove by on a motorcycle look at me
went and pointed i went
oh he went like the face like i will
arrest you on the spot if you don't pull
that car over i was like oh
comply with the with the police i mean i
got beat up by the cops a number of
times there you go
they shouldn't be a-holes they they they
are public servants that's another thing
i agree your strategy but we shouldn't
be there in the first place they should
understand that they have a public duty
to serve and they should actually be
responsible for serving
it's true i i think you know the fact
that we often end up in this situation
where we're like oh i understand they're
mad let's just be very nice to them
we shouldn't have to but i do think i i
do
think that you know understanding the
the the strategy and tactics of
yeah you know be successful yeah yeah
you know you could be you know tactful
you could be respectful but doesn't mean
you have to overly brown nose and kiss
their butts you shouldn't have to do
that would you if you could pick cops to
be
robots would you no would you absolutely
not
because you had a lot of emotional
experiences with them i think right
probably more than anyone at the table
well i i got the crap beat on me a
number of times for
you know not even breaking the law for
hanging out in the wrong crowd the wrong
neighborhood and you know growing up in
new york did you look black at the time
i find it hard to believe that you got
treated poorly by the police uh well
you're white
well i grew up in in brooklyn new york
city but you're white i mean
you've got white privilege didn't you
show them your white privilege card in
new york city
in new york new york city a lot of it
was based on
the neighborhoods you were in well
you've seen the south park episode with
michael jackson
so uh michael jackson moves to south
park
and the police are at the department and
they're like what's this
a black man has moved moved in and he's
wealthy oh
my god and so they like raid his house
to arrest him and then when they see
that he's white they're like
what have we done oh god and then they
apologize
so southpaw has been on it what do you
think about robot police
i don't terminators
[Music]
a lot of the laws are bull crap so i
wouldn't want robots uh using them
anyway
and i'll say one thing before we move on
to super chats disorderly conduct what
does it mean
how could a robot determine whether or
not you were disorderly they can't
so you might get arrested for nothing
but anyway we'll read some super chats
all right let's see we got here fisk the
lombak says the hedge funds want to keep
all the rewards when they make risky
decisions and win
when they lose they want to get bailed
out and make everyone pay for their
losses
exactly nope oh here's one concussed
gamer says luke you should get tulsi
gabbard to wake tim up in the middle of
the night that's the one
hit me up tulsi uh follow me on twitter
and uh
we'll do that yeah so let's do it tell
us you know
well i'll just leave it at you we'd love
to have tulsi gabbard on that i think
tim would contain his rage
if yeah he busted him open at 3am that
would be weird like one of few people in
the world that you would like
okay i'm not gonna get angry i i gotta
be honest like i probably wouldn't get
mad at anybody walking in the moment
unless it was like someone wanted to
hurt me we should all dress up like
gorillas
okay and then storm tim in the middle i
like where this is headed yeah
actually i probably i'd probably get
really really really mad
because if if i get woken up i get
migraines unless i win what i'm talking
about
nasty migraines and then i'll get
nauseous palsy has the magic touch
no i'd probably got the power i'd
probably get a migraine it's not nice
tonight yeah you need your rem sleep
messes me up real bad
let's see we got here oh what's this oh
here's a bold one
insight on the aegis says david pakman
has gone insane please have him on he
needs help
half truth the half truth the only way
to explain please help
i'm not sure i understand i don't know
what happened with david pegman honestly
i used to watch a bit more of his stuff
i haven't recently uh
so i don't know what's he doing he's
doing really well congratulations to him
though uh
you know i've seen some of his videos
pop up and he's getting a ton of views
that's cool unless he's saying crazy
things
i don't know he's getting more and more
famous but doesn't have like a grounded
group of friends
maybe i've actually known david for a
really really long time i like that guy
yeah yeah we have our disagreements i
was watching him since like right when
he started
when he was getting like 50 views 300
views who is this again david
david pakman he had this really famous
moment where he had the westboro baptist
church on his show and then anonymous
hacked their website in real time
so it's like you know he's been around
for a minute but let's uh let's read
some more as well
let's see what super chats we uh we got
we got dj strickland saying i didn't
like jason years ago when he was ragging
on the raiders but caught a youtube
video of his opinions last year about
america god bless brother
there you go your sports opinions are
bad but your american opinions were you
pulling out the raiders when they
actually sucked
i lived in kansas city oh i'm not and i
covered the chiefs
you know and so he's just caught up in
the chiefs raiders rivals
i got i got to tell you guys i think
we're gonna have a really really funny
bonus segment
because i already know we're talking
about i'm not gonna say anything right
now but trust me you're gonna love it
it's gonna be really funny we're gonna
laugh
and uh you definitely wanna go to
timcast.com become members or or you can
wait because we'll post the video and
then you can decide then but i think
it'll be hilarious it'll be fun
jason's going to be jason's is great so
i think we got a good segment
uh mitch l says one of your best guest
big jay you are the man
oh yeah thank you man we gotta everybody
loves you looks brandon freeman says
love jason whitlock love this format and
guess
you guys have been been having on thanks
for the great shows
right on jamie richard says buy some
stunks
and then posted seven rocket emojis
and it says colon rocket colon i guess
it's how you type the emoji
carl angstrom says been sharing your
channels hard for a while here keep the
truth coming
greatly appreciate it please please
share it helps josh martinez says
finally i can lurk in the cnn comment
section and um upvote each one in good
conscience
it's about time we had a good day
trumpism
omegablade says hi tim check out john
shaffer's
sons of liberty one of the songs jekyll
island lyrics mentioned ending the fed
sounds like uh ron paul the kind of band
yeah let's see we got let's see some of
these
gareth green goes on to say let me be
clear though the
this anti-short this storming of wall
street is glorious
it is the beauty of the true free market
that human hands cannot control
oh i think there's probably another one
i missed the heir from earlier
yes but i think maybe he had another one
it's hard because sometimes they get
broken up
here we go this one's important chris
geitzy says watching reddit ruin
people's retirements funds for the lulls
is like watching antifa burn small
business to fight the establishment
you know that that is one of the the
questions being mentioned about hedge
funds
are they managing people's retirement
accounts and betting it all and losing
it all jeez
look it's still an issue of the
establishment crony elites rigging the
game to enrich
a small group of people and they are
using these retirement funds to do so
so right it's different if you have a
business
and then someone comes and burns it down
as collateral damage as opposed to if
you're giving hedge fund managers
money to invest and ignorantly not
knowing that they're gaming the system
when you're you know you get to choose
how risky of an investment you want to
make
as an individual so that's a personal
decision that a lot of people are making
so
that's up to them bobby lane says luke i
always vote with my dollar which is why
i'm leaving a super chat
keep it the good work over there and i'm
ready uh i'm really glad to see
wall street bets making the rich big sad
lol alex jones 2024.
oh geez there we go
psycho dwarf says tim fact of the day a
time on target artillery attack is
called a stone
ah yes interesting i don't know that's a
reference to but probably something
important
someone said what is it uh spell checker
stunk interesting nobody knows what it
means stonks
yeah well yeah it's just a slang term
right it means luke said stonk went
earlier when he was in school
it's a meme stunks oh it is yes yeah
it's awesome michael tierney says we
just need the 99 to stop buying from
companies like amazon and walmart
spend at small business to keep the
money in the community lockdown transfer
of wealth opened my eyes to this
and instantly cancelled prime and go to
local stores it's a very very good point
that's a tough one for me yeah it i i
watch a lot of amazon prime
videos i'm watching one right now
america this is us or something like
that it's a
about american history i i think about
getting away from amazon
well we i've been going more to a uh uh
more regional chain grocery store
instead of walmart because we just go to
walmart at a time i don't want to go to
walmart anymore oh yeah i never go
anywhere yeah so now it's like trying to
avoid it but
it's rough man does prime does amazon
own twitch they own twitch don't they
i don't know they gave me prime benefits
for twitch for uh
red dead redemption i got a bunch of
in-game benefits for having prime
oh they're everywhere let's see
anglo-saxonite says
look into pelosi buying visa stock after
she helped pass a law that helped visa
she and her husband made millions
wouldn't be surprised
gareth green says fyi poland was a
soviet satellite but it was officially
an independent nation
it wasn't actually part of the soviet
union it was part of the russian empire
from the from the napoleonic wars until
world war one though
after it was partitioned out of
existence in the late 1700s
yeah amazon owns twitch okay
yep billion dollar company matthew
herbeck says you know what
i feel for these hedge funders maybe i
can offer a glimmer of hope
there's night school cut your spending
maybe pick up another part-time job
think of a change of trade
learn to code work longer hours where
they are probably
they are going to get a thousand four
hundred dollar check soon so
they got that going forward no actually
it's based on last year's income
i believe where they probably made
millions of dollars so now that they're
broke and destitute they're not even
going to get that
[Music]
sympathy too bad stevie b says a stock
is only worth the next person will pay
90 of those buying gme will lose wealth
will be
destroyed when stock gap down don't
touch gme
it's a good point it's true but you have
to think about three million people
each putting in a couple hundred bucks
the maximum loss for them is
a couple hundred bucks so it's bad some
people bet big and they'll lose big for
sure
but these hedge funds bet way big with
no bottom
and so the more people keep buying up
the more the the longest there's massive
demand it'll keep going up
and then these hedge funds are going to
be in serious trouble how did gamestop
make out
after all this are they actually getting
fiat from the stock purchases
so my so there there is some people are
saying that maybe gamestop will issue
more stock
to raise capital to help save the
company uh
i think some people pointed out that
executives of the company sold a long
time ago when it was at like 30 bucks
and so they got out while they could
ultimately it's irrational the money is
just being traded between
people not the company the company could
theoretically you know
raise capital somehow they may have
already done it i wonder if gamestop
will take the opportunity in the pr to
actually make some positive changes to
survive
i think in my opinion if they can still
if it's not too late they need to make
gamestop kind of like steam yeah they
need to create
a browser-based game downloading system
and their brick and mortar stores should
become
event spaces with gaming competitions
local stuff
that should lead to regional state level
then regional then national
really promote the community they should
do board games card games video games
and they should sell stuff and if people
are playing the games online and
downloading kind of like how steam works
but then they go into the physical shop
as a member to compete
and then the winners get to go to the
you know the regional stuff that's going
to create a whole market
around a professional space new products
new economy that's the way you play it
maybe they won't do it maybe they can't
do it i don't know that's what i'd do if
i was them
grand chi says they are not afraid of
their buddies failing they are afraid of
losing
their money from newsroom to politicians
at their
uh all their wealth is at risk tell me
how many people got their money back
from
madoff this is the same yup they're
gonna be really really
let's move down here we got some more
from gareth green says i would like to
say
that hedge funds do provide a service to
those who invest in them like me and my
parents that said
i was revolted when our financial
manager expressed approval of massive
money printing in our last meeting i
disavow him
yeah man you know i have a lot of
friends and i've known for a really
really long time who have always been
really well off
and they're really good people who are
really aware the problem is the snooty
elites who think they're better than
everyone just because they were born
into it
and then they expanded mostly the people
exploit the system i guess some people
are bad people you know
i try not to be mean to people
bass player 2011 says sellers lost
almost 40 billion dollars trying to
short tesla
not hard to see why elon is loving this
yep uh jayasurin says i heard that elon
was only briefly the richest man in the
world and jeff bezos came back to the
top
after a day and elon was the richest guy
because of bezos's alimony to his wife
because of divorce that's for sure well
there you go bezos
split half his half his net worth with
his wife when they divorce
another half no oh i thought it was half
no i think it's less than that
lurch says enrique tario turns out to be
an fbi informant curious
i did do a segment about it but it was a
while ago i don't think it was it was
actually recent
let's uh we got we got way too many i'm
so sorry guys we got way too many super
chats but y'all are awesome and i really
appreciate it
chris pavedo says tim luke did you see
that governor newsome approved one
billion dollar tax bucks
in contracts to a chinese company for
n95 masks reported a few days ago
been pushing my family to leave ca even
though our special
needs son benefits from ca weather
that's a bummer man
definitely california is brutal i
escaped
yes i'm happy how long were you there 10
years
can you disclose where you went
afterwards yeah i'm in nashville okay
what decade were you in california 2010
to
2020. yeah i was there for part of that
too um i think they're getting rid of
newsome or they wanted to issue some
recall
we got a uh religious post here josh
shuster says jesus christ is god
he shed his sinless perfect blood to
atone for mankind's sin
corinthians 15 1 through 4 you must
trust jesus for salvation and not a
religion
or your own good works and that's uh
ephesians
2 ephesians 9 2 2 8 nine yeah i am not a
very particularly uh
big religious person but uh much respect
to those who uh express themselves
dr doctor says with the advent of
automation and the fact that humans as a
species is not evolving quick enough
compared to its computing machine so
we're going to have a mass displacement
of workers in the near future
30 years or so how do we as a society
figure out
a uh figure out how our bartering system
perhaps there's more but i think i got
the general idea um
who what was this someone mentioning
that canada is going to go full ubi or
something like
universal basic income is around the
corner and they really want to push it
they want everybody just getting money
hey they crash the market nobody owns
anything
and then they decide what you can have
that's the uh the elite global
authoritarianism i mean that's the great
reset basically
have you you've seen that right oh yeah
and you will own nothing and you will be
happy well they're talking about the
fourth industrial revolution with
technology and their advancements
particularly
in ai removing a huge swap of the labor
force
so that's literally what they're
discussing at davos right now that
they're calling the great to reset
the great redefining of capitalism aka
more centralization more control
more regulation justice more big
government all in
done in the name of social justice naomi
klein said this is all going to be
all the good things that they promised
are never going to happen all the bad
things and the consequences
are going to happen because of this
microsoft has patent zero six
zero six zero six something like that
and it's like uh it's an implantable
uh where it can measure your bio
activity and then pay you crypto we're
in a simulation bro yeah they want you
to like
it'll be able to register if you're
watching an ad on tv and if you watch
specific ads it'll
pay your account crypto just for
watching just for being a certain way
we got isaac lux he says first super
chat but newish viewer five months
recently
mi unemployment got stimulus so i wanted
to support you guys i watched your 10
a.m video and almost
hopped on the train but i saw this
coming well you know
i'll just shout out i really appreciate
it isaac but i do think if you are
on unemployment and you have a stimulus
you should keep all that you should you
should keep all that
um but if you really want to support the
show by all means i mean
i'm you know i'm a pretty lefty guy i
don't i don't like the idea of people
having money getting special access for
the most part
but it's just kind of how the system
works there's no real way around it
tim's gonna get
super rich and then distribute the
wealth to a bunch of people
we can't yeah i'm gonna leave my address
here when you
cut those socialist desires dude i was
when you know we saw mega millions hit a
billion dollars
i bought some tickets and i no lie i was
like as the guys printing it i'm like
i'm gonna give you a million dollars
and they started laughing i'm like no i
mean it if i want a billion dollars then
i'd give tons of money i give someone i
give it all away
i give almost all of it away i'm too i'm
i'm just i just give it away
luke would keep it bitcoin are you
kidding me
would you give the money away i if i had
millions yeah
without a doubt dude i just started
investing in all these people so much
people don't understand just like how
stupid rich people are that they don't
know even what to do with themselves
with that money
to be fair it might not help people it
might hurt them seriously a lot of
people who get a lot of money really
quickly
end up actually uh putting themselves in
very high graduation but i tell you what
i would do
i would go out go to random house knock
on the door and be like i was wondering
if there's any bill you're having
trouble with
and then they're like oh yeah you know i
got this one built like a thousand bucks
i'd be like here you are sir have a nice
day
so it's just enough to help them out
that one thing the problem with just
giving a random person a million bucks
is they don't know what to do with it
how do they put in the bank like so if i
actually won the lottery you might
actually cause a lot of stress and
problems for them by giving them too
much
but you wanna if you if you win the
lottery you wanna give them enough to
where they're jumping up and down
yes and they've alleviated a lot of
their problems but not to where
it's you know mo money mo probably yeah
yeah creating a situation where you just
give people money is a lot different
than creating opportunities
for people to earn money doing good
things if i had a whole bunch of crazy
stupid money i would literally build it
into developing
tech social media internet 2.0 like it
was before
that's what i would do start investing
in companies like startups you know
i would do those build an own
decentralized
central internet network that was the
internet of the old bringing it back on
its own servers on its own platforms and
giving people jobs and opportunities
to work in the future giving a service
that's going to free people
i tell you what i do i would pay off
tons of medical debt i think that's the
easiest i don't want to give money to
those companies right now
no but but buying debt is is like 10 of
the actual
costs so when occupy wall street
organized this thing
i forgot what it was called but uh they
raised a bunch of money and then they
you have this debt that's sitting that
they can't collect because the people
are destitute
so they say how about we resolve you
want 10 grand i'll give you a thousand
bucks and we'll consider it resolved and
say
deal and then the people who are in debt
are no longer in debt anymore there's
still the problem of them having to pay
taxes on it
so then you have to figure out a way to
give them enough money to where they can
cover all of the taxes so you'd have to
give them some money and pay their
medical bills i think that would be a
really good way to
to give way a lot of the money if you
won the lottery dude people don't
realize
if you won the billion dollar prize you
would have more liquid cash than elon
musk
you would give up about half of it to
the government you'd end up with
probably like 400 million because
the cash prize the net the total annuity
price is a billion but then the cash
payout if you
choose cash is 735 million then you pay
half of it
so you end up with you know just shy of
400 million
you'd have more liquid cash than most
billionaires in this country maybe even
in the planet because they have hard
assets that are very
very valuable but liquid not so much you
then have to figure out what to do with
it
it's not it's not it's not so easy but
let's be real if you're in the lottery
you'd be like richie rich
i would i was sitting here listening to
you guys i would
invest a lot of money in my school ball
state university
and i would make them teach things
that i that celebrated traditional
american values i'd run all the
marxists off campus and create an
entrepreneurial school that taught kids
how to start their own businesses oh
yeah i love that
that's what i and i hope my school
president's not listening to this
all right we're gonna we'll grab a
couple more uh super chats here
art vandelay says check out the new
thomas sowell documentary
on free to choose network and upcoming
bio by justin reilly
sowell is a national treasure he is a
he's a smart fellow
he's the second person that suggested
that in the last 20 what's the name of
the documentary i don't remember
you should watch uh shelby still did a
vid uh documentary
what killed michael brown also
interesting
all right we got jq nelson film says
whitlock heard you moved to nashville
from la
i just moved from nyc to nashville due
to the lockdown homelessness etc
do you think these big cities will come
back post coven also we go to the same
barber shop
oh he goes to collins barbershop uh
i don't think the big cities are going
to come back not to what they were
no i think and i was telling lydia when
she picked me up from the airport
i think that's a mistake for
conservative people
and conservative media outlets they need
to evacuate
new york and l.a quit playing away games
go play home games in texas
in tennessee in florida go
be with your customers and
you know i wish that fox news would
relocate to nashville
or dallas and that way lachlan murray or
lachlan murdoch or
any of them they would when they went
out and socialized
they'd go out and be amongst people who
thought like them yeah
rather than playing road games and being
intimidated
because the whole atmosphere around you
is so far
left there's a meme i tweeted today in
relation to this it says if lockdowns
weren't profitable cash cows for the
global billionaire class
they'd end tomorrow yeah yep good point
all right we got
james kaliri saying take this money you
capitalist pigs
love you guys appreciate it tilt rod
says on police reform
sir robert peel basically invented the
idea of a uniformed police force
i think you would appreciate his
original principles about policing
pelian principles
we abused the power of police by using
them as tax collectors
interesting well my friends thank you
all so much for all of your comments
and super chats we had a lot tonight and
as you know i we really can't get
through everybody but we try
but we are going to have another segment
coming up at timcast.com which is going
to be
at least i hope very funny and fun and
more relaxing and chill
and uh i can curse i was told yeah
you're gonna go
nuts yeah so it's gonna be just like two
hours without cuts
i'm shaking we did we well we do tell
everybody
they can cuss if they want but youtube
is just really nasty about it and we try
to be family friendly so it's really up
to up to you but everybody kind of
respects the idea that you know we'll
keep it down
but at teamcast.com we're going to go
crazy and it's going to be hilarious
we're going to be laughing so please go
to tempgus.com become a member
smash the like button subscribe to the
notification bell you can follow me on
twitter
instagram parlor why did i just say that
keep saying it stop it
parlor's coming back it is i don't know
maybe one day
mines at timcast and my other youtube
channels are youtube.comtimcast and
youtube.comtimcastnews
and we do the show monday to friday live
at 8 00 p.m so we will be back tomorrow
jason you want to shout out anything
you're working on your podcasts your
twitter which
you can check me out on twitter at
whitlock.json i'll just leave it at that
it's a good twitter account too i've
been following for a while so good no
you haven't been following what
yeah they unfo you unfollowed me i did
not follow
i know somebody did oh i follow you
trust me i've been heartbroken about it
lydia what did i say when you asked me
no i think i
loved it a long time i don't know
so when she mentioned she went ahead and
i was like yeah of course heck yeah
oh now i'm mad at twitter i've been mad
at twitter for a long time but
this has been happening there's also ron
coleman he's a lawyer
i've been unfollowed for him like five
times i don't unfollow him
and i literally was like damn i wonder
what i said
[Laughter]
i'll follow you right now luke you're
here this happens a lot by the way
also if you like to buy the t-shirt that
i'm wearing right now that says if you
trust
the government you don't know history
you can on
thebestpoliticoshirts.com thank you so
much for purchasing those t-shirts and
supporting me over at
we are change dot org it means a lot to
me thank you
yo what up everybody i'm ian crossland
you can follow me uh basically
all over the internet idiom crossland
and um probably gaming later tonight if
you want to follow me on twitch.tv
ian crossland i'll be firing out a tweet
to let you know when i go live
jason you mentioned that you were going
to be starting a show i know maybe it's
too premature to really talk
too premature it's exciting though i'm
going to follow you on twitter as well
i'm so offended at twitter yeah twitter
because i remember you tweeted something
in response to me and i immediately
followed you yeah and then
i guess i just needed to follow me by
six or seven months
trust me i i have the day written down
next to my
heart my and and but we've also read out
kick articles before too i think from
you yeah
yeah no twitter i'm saying this in all
seriousness
there have been two podcasts i wanted to
come on and i can now cross this off
oh dude you're welcome to come back it's
fun joe rogan is the other one tim poole
and joe rogan are my favorites in this
life it's way bigger though
i feel like if you if you're interviewed
by tim paul and joe rogan you've made it
i
honestly i swear i promise you then you
gotta get interviewed by tim poole and
joe rogan at the same time that would be
incredible
like like jack everyone keep everyone
always brings up that episode about
twitter or whatever
i am eternally grateful to joe for
having me on because i told the story
before but like when joe asked me to do
it i was like are you serious like
i got i just i like 100 000 subscribers
on youtube i'm like what am i doing i
don't think you smiled once on the show
too as well
he did not he never broke character he
never broke character well because
for me in their ass oh i'm sorry
you were right though well no no it was
uh like when i when i went in
that show i didn't even care about the
cameras i was like oh these guys
like i'm gonna say some stuff anyway
anyway we'll save it for the bonus
segment we also got sour patch let's
press on them buttons yes i'm pushing
all the buttons i had a great time
talking with jason when i picked him up
from the airport
you guys can follow me on social media
if i can recall i am real sour patch
lids on
gab and instagram and i am just sour
patch lids
sour patch lids on mines and twitter
right on
the conversation continues at
timcast.com
a special segment talking about some
funny stuff related to the uh
the gorilla t-shirts and uh you know
we'll have some fun with it so thanks
for hanging out everybody
and we'll see you over at timcast.com
you